Let's talk groceries, specifically your groceries with Instacart. You want your groceries just the way you like them, right? Well, the Instacart app lets you do just that. They have a new preference picker that lets you pick how ripe or unripe you want your bananas. Shoppers can see your preferences up front, helping guide their choices. Instacart, get groceries just how you like. Welcome to our second drink of business ethics. I loved this episode.
来聊聊杂货吧，特别是你用 Instacart 购买的杂货。你想要买到称心如意的杂货，对吧？Instacart 应用程序就能满足你的需求。他们有一个新的偏好选择功能，让你能挑选香蕉的成熟度。购物者可以预先看到你的偏好，从而引导他们的选择。Instacart，买到你心仪的杂货。欢迎来到我们的第二杯“商业道德”节目。我太喜欢这一集了。
And we finally got to have Amy Ryan on the podcast. What a fun interview. Yes. Oh, my gosh. She is just the best. She gave us such great behind the scenes details about her time playing Holly Flax, aka Hollis Flax. But that's not all. Listen, we put the word out and we asked you all, what were your favorite moments from the episode Business Ethics? And I just want to say thank you to everyone who responded. It was really fun to read your answers. And there was one particular scene that got a fan mail flurry. Tanish C from India said, So I basically love the opening scene where Michael and Holly are dancing with the headbands on and the binder book and they are singing, let's get ethical, ethical.
我们终于请到了艾米·瑞恩（Amy Ryan）来参加播客。这次采访太有趣了。是的。天哪。她真是太棒了。她为我们提供了很多关于她饰演霍莉·弗拉克斯（Holly Flax），也就是霍利斯·弗拉克斯（Hollis Flax）时的幕后细节。但这还不是全部。听着，我们发布了消息，问大家在《商业道德》这一集中最喜欢的时刻是什么。我想对所有回复的人说声谢谢。阅读你们的回答真的很有趣。有一个特定的场景引发了粉丝来信的狂潮。来自印度的 Tanish C 说，我基本上喜欢开场戏，迈克尔和霍莉戴着头带，拿着活页书跳舞，他们唱着“让我们变得有道德，有道德”。
I actually laughed so hard. And Karen Y from Ecuador said, it is also her favorite moment, and she has a background catch. Karen says, at three minutes, 24 seconds, you can see two red marks on
我真的笑得很大声。来自厄瓜多尔的 Karen Y 说，这也是她最喜欢的时刻，她发现了一个背景细节。Karen 说，在 3 分 24 秒时，你可以看到
Michael's forehead from the headband he was wearing for the dance. But at three minutes 31 seconds, the red marks are completely gone. We must have shot on two different days. I guess. Well, I love this fan mail flurry, and we thought this moment was adorable. We talk about it, but we didn't play it, and I think we should hear it. Let's hear it. Let's get ethical, ethical. I want to get ethical.
迈克尔的额头上有两个红印，那是他跳舞时戴的头带留下的。但在 3 分 31 秒时，红印完全消失了。我想我们一定是在两天内拍摄的。好吧，我喜欢这股粉丝来信狂潮，我们觉得这个时刻很可爱。我们谈论过它，但没有播放它，我觉得我们应该听听。让我们听听。让我们变得有道德，有道德。我想变得有道德。
Let's get into ethics, yeah. Let me hear your Dundamifflin talk, your body talk. Let me hear your body talk. Woo! All right. Can we just say their idea of inserting, like, new lyrics and trying to make it fit is, let me hear your Dundermifflin talk. Your Dundermifflin talk.
让我们进入道德，耶。让我听听你的邓德米夫林（Dunder Mifflin）谈话，你的身体谈话。让我听听你的身体谈话。呜！好吧。我们能说他们插入新歌词并试图让它合拍的想法是，让我听听你的邓德米夫林谈话。你的邓德米夫林谈话。
Yeah. It cracked me up. I also just love how Amy Ryan as an actress was just so up. for this bit and just match Steve Corell in his silliness. It was so fun to be on set and watch that. I mean, we got to be in the audience. And the thing when you rewatch it is, there's a good, I don't know, it feels like a few minutes, where they're only dancing and they're not even singing yet. It's pretty great. All right. Another fan favorite moment comes from Chantelle E. She says, my husband has asked me every week since I started listening to the podcast if it was time for this
是的。这让我笑翻了。我也很喜欢艾米·瑞恩作为一名演员，她非常乐于参与这个片段，并与史蒂夫·卡瑞尔（Steve Carell）的傻气相得益彰。在片场观看那一幕真是太有趣了。我的意思是，我们当时就在观众席里。当你重温它时，你会发现，不知道，感觉有几分钟，他们只是在跳舞，甚至还没开始唱歌。这真的很棒。好吧。另一个粉丝最喜欢的时刻来自 Chantelle E。她说，自从我开始听这个播客以来，我丈夫每周都会问我是否到了这一集。
episode. His favorite moment of the entire series is when Michael finds out that Jim and Pam are engaged. The question is, does Steve improvise tackling Jim or was that scripted? I'm so excited that I'm finally able to ask this question for my husband, exclamation point. There was also lots of all caps in there. Yes, it's true. So, Shantel, we did talk about this moment. when we first broke down the episode. And it was scripted, but we never described how it's read in the script. Which is very funny. So tell your hubby, I went to our shooting draft, and here is the original scripted scene.
他整个系列中最喜欢的时刻是迈克尔发现吉姆和帕姆订婚的时候。问题是，史蒂夫是即兴扑向吉姆的，还是剧本里写的？我很高兴终于能为我丈夫问这个问题，感叹号。里面还有很多大写字母。是的，这是真的。所以，Chantelle，我们在第一次拆解这一集时确实谈到了这个时刻。它是剧本里写的，但我们从未描述过剧本里是怎么写的。这非常有趣。所以告诉你丈夫，我查了我们的拍摄草稿，这是最初的剧本场景。
And the over-the-top commotion actually originally started with Kelly. Kelly comes into the bullpen and she says, what's everyone talking about? And Creed says, the tall guy got engaged. And then here's the scene description. Kelly screams and falls to the ground uncontrollably. Michael comes in for the day and sees Kelly on the floor. He says, what's going on? Pam quickly with a voiceover jumping in says,
这种夸张的骚动最初其实是从凯利（Kelly）开始的。凯利走进办公区，她说，大家在谈论什么？克里德（Creed）说，那个高个子订婚了。然后是场景描述。凯利尖叫着无法控制地倒在地上。迈克尔进来上班，看到凯利在地板上。他说，怎么了？帕姆快速地用画外音插话说，
nothing, Michael, just saying hi. Kelly, barely able to get it out, says, Jim and Pam are engaged. And Michael goes to be married. Three question marks, three exclamation points. Michael tackles Jim. Yeah. So funny.
没什么，迈克尔，只是打个招呼。凯利几乎说不出话来，说，吉姆和帕姆订婚了。迈克尔说，要结婚了？三个问号，三个感叹号。迈克尔扑向吉姆。是的。太搞笑了。
Well, another fan favorite moment was marriage. of his confession. You know, when she shares that she's been sleeping with a hammer mill paper rep for the last six years for lower prices on paper and Outback Steakhouse gift certificates. Sean C. from Maryland said, I like when corporate just doesn't give a shit about what Meredith is doing. And Lindsay S. from Canada also loved that storyline and said, I loved it when corporate said that as long as Dunder Mifflin was getting a discount, they were fine with it. Also, when Meredith shares her barbecue with the office is peak. that tag at the end and everyone is eating Outback Steakhouse and they're all so happy about it.
好吧，另一个粉丝最喜欢的时刻是梅雷迪思（Meredith）的供述。你知道，当她分享说她过去六年来一直与一家锤磨机纸张代表睡觉，以换取更低的纸张价格和澳拜客牛排馆（Outback Steakhouse）的礼品卡时。来自马里兰州的 Sean C 说，我喜欢公司根本不在乎梅雷迪思在做什么。来自加拿大的 Lindsay S 也喜欢那个故事情节，并说，我喜欢公司说只要邓德米夫林能得到折扣，他们就没意见。还有，当梅雷迪思与办公室分享她的烧烤时，那是巅峰时刻。结尾的那个标签，每个人都在吃澳拜客牛排，他们都为此感到非常高兴。
It's pretty amazing. So thanks for writing in everyone and sharing your favorite moments from this episode. We'll be doing second drinks every Monday. So write in your fan favorite moments over at OfficeLadies.com. And now here is Business Ethics. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together.
这太神奇了。所以感谢大家的来信，分享你们在这一集中最喜欢的时刻。我们每周一都会做“第二杯”节目。所以请在 OfficeLadies.com 上写下你们粉丝最喜欢的时刻。现在是《商业道德》。我是珍娜·费舍（Jenna Fischer）。我是安吉拉·金赛（Angela Kinsey）。我们一起出演了《办公室》。
And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode. of the office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hi, everyone. Hey, guys. What's up, Ange?
我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会拆解《办公室》的一集，并提供只有两个在场的人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是“办公室女士”。大家好。嘿，伙计们。怎么了，Ange？
What's up with you and your cute pants? Thank you for saying that. I noticed them right away. Here's the thing. I hit a wall with sweatpants. What? I know. Guys, one of the reasons we started this podcast was because I wanted a job I could do in sweatpants.
你和你的可爱裤子怎么了？谢谢你这么说。我一眼就注意到了。是这样的。我穿运动裤穿腻了。什么？我知道。伙计们，我们开始这个播客的原因之一是因为我想要一份我可以穿着运动裤做的工作。
Uh-huh. You know, we talked about that a lot early on. Yeah. Well, I counted. after 409 days of wearing sweatpants. I mean, not every single day, but for the most part, for the last 409 days, I would get out of bed and put on sweatpants. Right.
嗯哼。你知道，我们早期经常谈论这个。是的。好吧，我数了一下。在穿了 409 天运动裤之后。我的意思是，不是每一天，但在过去 409 天里，大部分时间，我起床后都会穿上运动裤。对。
I actually had several pairs of pants that were made of the same material as my sheets. Like a jersey. They're a bamboo. Okay. Made by the same company that makes my sheets. Listen, if I can have pants made by people that make bedding. That's what I thought. It's like I'm just wearing my bed around all day.
我其实有几条裤子是用和我床单一样的材料做的。像平纹针织布。它们是竹纤维的。好的。和生产我床单的公司是同一家。听着，如果我能穿上由生产床上用品的人制作的裤子。我就是这么想的。感觉就像我整天穿着我的床一样。
I thought I'd hit the jackpot. Okay, so after 409 days of this, I hit a wall. And I was like, I need to wear pants, actual pants. So I went out and I bought a pair of pants, Angela. I'm going to stand up and I'm going to show you. I'm going to describe them to you. I'm going to take a picture. They kind of look like camouflage, but like very sassy cargo kind of pants.
我以为我中了大奖。好吧，在这样过了 409 天之后，我穿腻了。我就想，我需要穿裤子，真正的裤子。所以我出去买了一条裤子，安吉拉。我要站起来给你看。我要向你描述它们。我要拍张照片。它们看起来有点像迷彩，但又是非常时髦的工装裤。
Yeah, that's what I was going for. Sassy cargo. Yeah, I love a sassy cargo. Okay. All right, so here's the thing. I think I'm so used to wearing sweatpants. I'm in the dressing room, and I don't know which size of pants to buy. Because you've been wearing the baggy breeches. That's right. I went back and forth and back and forth, and I went with the bigger size. And now I've been wearing them for what? I don't know, an hour. Now they're all stretched out. They're too big. And look what happens. Now they're falling down. And I've got long crotch. Long crotch, lady. Oh, I see it. You have long crotch. Gals, you know. what we're talking about. When like the seam of your pants is like halfway between your thigh and your
是的，这就是我想要的。时髦工装裤。是的，我喜欢时髦工装裤。好的。好吧，是这样的。我想我太习惯穿运动裤了。我在试衣间里，不知道该买什么尺寸的裤子。因为你一直穿着宽松的裤子。没错。我反复试穿，最后选了大一号的。现在我已经穿了，什么？不知道，一个小时了。现在它们都撑大了。它们太大了。看看发生了什么。现在它们往下掉。我的裆部显得很长。长裆，女士。哦，我看到了。你的裆部很长。姑娘们，你们知道我们在说什么。当你的裤缝在你的大腿和
knees, that's long crotch. So what do I do? I've worn them. I can't take them back and get the smaller size. I think I could get someone to alter it in the back. You know, I like the sassy cargo minus the long crotch. What are we doing today? All right. Let me tell you. For those of you guys wanting to know what we're doing today. It is Business Ethics Season 5 Episode 3. Oh yeah. It is really. It is written by Ryan Coe and directed by Jeffrey Blitz. Love it. Here is a summary. Jim reluctantly reveals him and Pam's engagement to the office.
膝盖之间时，那就是长裆。那我该怎么办？我已经穿过了。我不能退货换小一号的。我想我可以找人把后面改一下。你知道，我喜欢时髦工装裤，减去长裆。我们今天要做什么？好吧。让我告诉你。对于那些想知道我们今天要做什么的人。是《商业道德》，第五季第三集。哦耶。确实是。它由瑞安·科（Ryan Koh）编剧，杰弗里·布里茨（Jeffrey Blitz）导演。喜欢它。这是一个摘要。吉姆不情愿地向办公室透露了他和帕姆的订婚。
Mm-hmm. We'll discuss. Following Ryan's recent actions, corporate has required Holly to conduct a seminar on business ethics. Michael offers immunity to anyone willing to confess to dishonesty at work. What are we like an episode of Survivor? I know. You get immunity. everything you say. And then we're going to light the torch for you. Well, some things are revealed.
嗯哼。我们会讨论。继瑞安最近的行为之后，公司要求霍莉进行一场关于商业道德的研讨会。迈克尔为任何愿意承认工作中不诚实行为的人提供豁免权。我们是什么，像《幸存者》节目吗？我知道。你得到豁免权。你说的每一件事。然后我们要为你点燃火炬。好吧，一些事情被揭露了。
Again, we will discuss. And it's going to cause a rift between Michael and Holly. Yeah. Meanwhile, Jim makes Dwight observe the company's time theft policy. And Meredith provides outbacked steakhouse takeout to the entire office. So that's our summary. Would you like Fast fact number one? I really would. All right. New writer alert. Oh, writer Ryan Coe has joined the staff for season five. Hello, Ryan. Welcome. Hello, Ryan. He was only with us for one season as he left to work on Cougar Town. Oh, we knew lots of folks on Cougar Town. We sure did, busy Phillips. Oh, yeah. He is also a writer and co-executive producer of the Simpsons. Welcome Ryan. Welcome. Fast fact number two, no Pam. Outside of the cold open where you hear Pam's voice, there is no Pam in this episode. But there was Pam. There was, you guys. There was. I filmed a bunch of scenes at art school and they all got cut out.
同样，我们会讨论。这会导致迈克尔和霍莉之间的裂痕。是的。与此同时，吉姆让德怀特（Dwight）遵守公司的工时盗窃政策。梅雷迪思为整个办公室提供了澳拜客牛排馆的外卖。这就是我们的摘要。你想要第一个速记事实吗？我真的很想要。好吧。新编剧警报。哦，编剧瑞安·科加入了第五季的员工队伍。你好，瑞安。欢迎。你好，瑞安。他只和我们合作了一季，因为他离开去制作《熟女镇》（Cougar Town）了。哦，我们认识很多《熟女镇》的人。我们当然认识，比茜·菲利普斯（Busy Philipps）。哦，是的。他也是《辛普森一家》的编剧和联合执行制片人。欢迎瑞安。欢迎。第二个速记事实，没有帕姆。除了在冷开场中你能听到帕姆的声音外，这一集中没有帕姆。但帕姆确实存在。确实存在，伙计们。确实存在。我在艺术学校拍了一堆场景，它们都被剪掉了。
I know. I saw in the deleted scenes. There's like three. Well, I'm going to talk about them. Okay. As we break down this episode, on office ladies, Pam will be inserted into this episode again. She will live again. She will. And also, Jenna, there was an amazing Ryan Kevin Runner that got deleted for time. And it's great. And I'm going to bring that up. You guys, we're bringing it all back today. in business ethics. Fast fact number three, Amy Ryan. Holly is here today.
我知道。我在删除的场景中看到了。大概有三个。好吧，我要谈谈它们。好的。当我们拆解这一集时，在“办公室女士”节目中，帕姆将再次被插入到这一集中。她将再次活过来。她会的。还有，珍娜，有一个很棒的瑞安和凯文的片段因为时间原因被删除了。它很棒。我要提一下。伙计们，我们今天要把一切都带回来，在《商业道德》中。第三个速记事实，艾米·瑞恩。霍莉今天在这里。
We interviewed Amy Ryan all about this episode and her time on the office. Let's hear it. And welcome to office ladies. Hi, office ladies. I'm so glad to be here and to see your beautiful faces and the interior of your closets. Yeah, I was going to say, welcome to our closets. Amy, it's so good. to see you. Holly Flacks. Oh my gosh. Hollis. We found out your name is Hollis. Is that right?
我们采访了艾米·瑞恩，谈论了这一集和她在《办公室》的时光。让我们听听。欢迎来到“办公室女士”。嗨，办公室女士。我很高兴来到这里，看到你们美丽的脸庞和你们衣橱的内部。是的，我正想说，欢迎来到我们的衣橱。艾米，见到你真好。霍莉·弗拉克斯。天哪。霍利斯。我们发现你的名字是霍利斯。是这样吗？
Because it's on your little name placard. Yes. I don't know if I ever knew that. That's a really good tip. Would you have played the character differently? Tell her, I would have been much more, you know, refined. I feel like Hollis is much more refined. And maybe I would have had an accent. Oh. I don't know. I think if your character had been a Supreme Court judge, you might have gone by Hollis. Yes. But you ended up in HR, and so you went with the less formal Holly, maybe. That's correct.
因为在你的小名牌上写着。是的。我不知道我是否曾经知道这一点。这是一个非常好的提示。你会以不同的方式演绎这个角色吗？告诉她，我会更，你知道，文雅一些。我觉得霍利斯更文雅。也许我会带点口音。哦。我不知道。我想如果你的角色是一位最高法院法官，你可能会叫霍利斯。是的。但你最终在人力资源部工作，所以你选择了不那么正式的霍莉，也许。那是正确的。
Yeah. When you run HR, you really want to be more approachable, you know, kind of a warm, fuzzy character. That makes sense. Holly was a warm, fuzzy character, and we're in love with her. I am so enamored by Holly and Michael. Jen and I have cried because Michael is, like, finally with someone that here. about him. She's dead.
是的。当你管理人力资源时，你真的想更平易近人，你知道，那种温暖、毛茸茸的角色。这说得通。霍莉是一个温暖、毛茸茸的角色，我们爱死她了。我被霍莉和迈克尔迷住了。珍娜和我曾经哭过，因为迈克尔终于和某个人在一起了，那个人在乎他。她死了。
Well, in watching it, episode by episode, and just four years of Michael not having a partner to suddenly see a woman partner with him and joke with him and like his jokes, I did. I cried. Oh, you know, in preparation for meeting you both today, I rewatched the episode. I hadn't watched the show in a long time. I saved her, like, popping in the room when my daughter was on her third pass of the series. But it is so moving. I think all the characters are so moving.
嗯，在逐集观看时，仅仅是迈克尔四年没有伴侣，突然看到一个女人与他搭档，与他开玩笑，喜欢他的笑话，我确实哭了。哦，你知道，为了今天见到你们俩，我重温了这一集。我很久没看这个节目了。我保存了她，比如当我女儿第三次刷这个系列时，她突然出现在房间里。但这太感人了。我认为所有的角色都太感人了。
I know everyone's talked about this before, but that element of the family, you know, it's not a workplace. It's actually a family. And that really comes through so beautifully. But Holly and Michael, I mean, I've always said, you know, there's a lid for every pot. So they finally found each other, but she has a high tolerance, I suppose. for that kind of guy. Well, we always like to ask people, Amy, how did you come to be on the show? And we did a little research.
我知道每个人以前都谈论过这一点，但那种家庭的元素，你知道，它不是一个工作场所。它实际上是一个家庭。这真的体现得非常美妙。但霍莉和迈克尔，我的意思是，我一直说，你知道，锅配盖。所以他们终于找到了彼此，但她有很高的容忍度，我想。对于那种男人。好吧，我们总是喜欢问人们，艾米，你是怎么来到这个节目的？我们做了一些研究。
Paul Lieberstein told us that they came to you. They were huge fans. But that you had simultaneously mentioned to your agent you might like to do our show. Yes. So what was that process? Yeah. How did it go down? That is true.
保罗·利伯斯坦（Paul Lieberstein）告诉我们，他们找到了你。他们是你的超级粉丝。但你同时也向你的经纪人提到你可能想参加我们的节目。是的。那么那个过程是怎样的？是的。它是怎么发生的？那是真的。
And the timing was eerie because I did say that's, to my agent. It was soon after the Oscars. And I was like, you know, I'm doing a lot of dramas. And if I have any kind of cachet right now at this moment, I want to do a comedy and I want to do a comedy like The Office, because I was never good at the four-camera sitcom. I just felt too much pressure and it wasn't like, I always feel like characters weren't really rooted in a reality, the way the office was. And that goes back to how I met Paul Lieberstein. We were both employed on The Naked Truth and he was a writer. My agent had kind of reached out, and at the same time, Paul had reached out, I guess, to him.
而且时机非常诡异，因为我确实对我的经纪人说了。那是在奥斯卡颁奖典礼后不久。我说，你知道，我演了很多剧情片。如果我现在有任何名气，我想演一部喜剧，我想演一部像《办公室》那样的喜剧，因为我从来不擅长四机位情景喜剧。我总是感到压力太大，而且我觉得角色并不像《办公室》那样扎根于现实。这要追溯到我如何认识保罗·利伯斯坦。我们都在《赤裸真相》（The Naked Truth）工作，他是编剧。我的经纪人联系了他，与此同时，我想保罗也联系了他。
I don't know who got there first, but it was, I really think it was like about the same week. And Paul had mentioned that he was also a fan of The Wire, as were some of the other writers. So it was kind of a culmination of all those worlds coming together. And did they pitch the character of Holly to you, or did you, like, have a script to read anything? I don't remember reading a script. I remember saying, hearing it was a one episode only and potential love interest, which obviously I knew was code from, we'll see how you do, kid, if we have you back. I remember also, because I was a big fan of the British series, David finally gets a woman who likes him too. So it was loosely based, I think, on her for the first episode.
我不知道谁先到的，但我真的认为大概是在同一周。保罗提到他也是《火线》（The Wire）的粉丝，其他一些编剧也是。所以这就像所有这些世界汇聚在一起的顶点。他们向你推销霍莉这个角色了吗，还是你读过剧本之类的？我不记得读过剧本。我记得听到它只是一集，是一个潜在的恋爱对象，显然我知道那是代码，意思是，我们看看你表现如何，孩子，如果我们让你回来。我还记得，因为我是英国系列的忠实粉丝，大卫终于找到了一个也喜欢他的女人。所以我认为第一集是松散地基于她。
and then our group took it to a different level. So there was no script that I was privy to, but I knew the kind of general idea of it. What was it like to walk onto the set for the first time? Really weird. It's really weird. It's also then a now I'm a fan of the American version. And you start to know the set, obviously,
然后我们的团队把它提升到了一个新的水平。所以我没有看过任何剧本，但我知道它的大致想法。第一次走进片场是什么感觉？真的很奇怪。真的很奇怪。而且现在我是美国版的粉丝。你开始了解片场，显然，
from the comfort of your couch or your tablet or whatever it is. You know, when you get there, it's like, oh, everything's smaller. And then there you all were so warm and welcoming. You know, there's always an element of being the new kid in school and how's that going to go down. But, and also you guys at this point are on a really massive, you know, big hit show. And it was the most down-to-earth, welcoming, warm group of people,
从你的沙发或平板电脑或任何东西的舒适中。你知道，当你到达那里时，就像，哦，一切都更小了。然后你们都在那里，如此温暖和热情。你知道，总是有一种作为学校新生的元素，那会怎么样。但是，而且你们在这一点上也是一个非常巨大的，你知道，大热的节目。这是我见过的最脚踏实地、热情、温暖的一群人，
like true ensemble that I met. And even to the end, I feel like, you know, you hear all those stories. of shows that become so successful and the bad behavior starts coming out and, you know, but at least I didn't see any of that. And I just thought it was always about the work and you guys really set such a beautiful tone there. Well, you said you rewatched business ethics and one of my favorite parts is when you and Michael do the Let's Get Physical. Yes, that's so funny. I watched that with my daughter, and we watched that scene like two times in a row, just him reaching in trying to hit the play button. And then the two of you running in with those headbands and your dance number.
真正的合奏。即使到最后，我觉得，你知道，你听过所有那些变得非常成功的节目的故事，坏行为开始出现，你知道，但至少我没有看到任何那种情况。我只是觉得它总是关于工作，你们真的在那里定下了如此美丽的基调。好吧，你说你重温了《商业道德》，我最喜欢的部分之一是你和迈克尔做“让我们变得有道德”。是的，那太搞笑了。我和我女儿一起看了，我们把那个场景看了两遍，就是他伸手试图按下播放键。然后你们两个戴着那些头带跑进来，还有你们的舞蹈表演。
How did you guys come up with all that? What do we do? Well, the headbands, I have to give credit for wardrobe. I mean, that was pretty wonderful and ridiculous. Just having that visual. The dance, honestly, that's me just following Steve. I anything, you know, I always, anything that I was lucky enough to be partnered, paired with Steve, I was smart enough to get in the sidecar of that motorcycle ride. Like, I'm not going to lead this here. He's going to have a better idea. So that was, that was just me kind of, you know, follow, yeah, literally following his choreography.
你们是怎么想出这一切的？我们做什么？好吧，头带，我必须归功于服装部门。我的意思是，那真是太棒了，太荒谬了。仅仅有那种视觉效果。舞蹈，老实说，那只是我跟着史蒂夫。我任何，你知道，我总是，任何我有幸与史蒂夫搭档、配对的事情，我都足够聪明，能坐进那辆摩托车的边车里。就像，我不会在这里带头。他会有更好的主意。所以那只是我，你知道，跟随，是的，字面意思上跟随他的编舞。
Well, I wasn't there because my character was at art school. So I am super bomb. that I did not get to see that done live. Did you guys do like tons of takes of it? You were there, Ann, do you guys remember? It was so hard not to laugh. Like from the minute it started, and when I was rewatching it, Oscar's face says it all. He's in the front. And I was like, I don't want to be in the front. Please don't put me in the front because I knew I was going to get so tickled. And Oscar does this thing when he's trying not to break. You know, we know each other's tales after all those years, where he kind of does this mouth open thing. And that's him. him trying not to laugh. So you go back and watch. Oscar's like, I'm going to. It was so funny.
好吧，我不在那里，因为我的角色在艺术学校。所以我超级难过，我没能亲眼看到那个表演。你们做了很多次拍摄吗？你在那里，安，你们记得吗？很难不笑。从它开始的那一刻起，当我重温它时，奥斯卡的脸说明了一切。他在前面。我就想，我不想在前面。请不要把我放在前面，因为我知道我会笑得不行。奥斯卡在试图不破功时会做这种事。你知道，经过那些年，我们了解彼此的底细，他会做这种嘴巴张开的动作。那就是他试图不笑。所以你回去看。奥斯卡就像，我要。这太搞笑了。
First of all, being in that conference, you know, that's kind of the most famous part of the set, right? And here we go and someone gets to present something. And it's better when, again, you're paired with someone next to you. But those scenes where I'm alone giving the conference, my hands are like white knuckle. I'm like trying to be like, you know, very casual holding my hands. But if you look closely, my hands are just. just like two iron fists of nerves. That's the other thing. Everyone always asks me, is the office, was that a lot of improv? And I said, no, it was, I remember scripty coming up to me, you know, correcting me for, like, of instead of at, like something really tiny. And I tell people and tell me if I'm wrong.
首先，在那个会议室里，你知道，那是片场最著名的部分，对吧？我们开始吧，有人要展示一些东西。而且当你再次与旁边的人配对时，效果更好。但那些我独自进行会议的场景，我的手像白指关节一样。我试图表现得，你知道，非常随意地握着我的手。但如果你仔细看，我的手只是像两个铁拳，紧张得要命。那是另一件事。每个人总是问我，《办公室》是不是有很多即兴表演？我说，不，它是，我记得剧本主管走过来，你知道，纠正我，比如把“of”改成“at”，像非常微小的东西。我告诉人们，如果我错了请告诉我。
I was like, it was heavily scripted. And then maybe by the third take, Steve would go off script first and then everyone would follow suit. That's my recollection of it. Would you say that's right? Absolutely. Yeah. And in that, I just think it was, again, like, you guys are so in tune with each other. And no one trying to beat anyone to the punchline.
我说，它是高度剧本化的。然后也许到了第三次拍摄，史蒂夫会先脱离剧本，然后每个人都会效仿。这就是我的回忆。你会说那是对的吗？绝对。是的。而且在这一点上，我只是认为，再次，就像，你们彼此之间如此协调。没有人试图在任何人之前抢到笑点。
It was just a constant setup. I thought it was just so perfect. I think that's why people can't really tell between the scripted and when it goes to improv. It was just so perfectly done. I wanted to ask you about those restaurant scenes. Oh, yeah. Coopers. There's that whole runner about the chastity belt where he's trying to explain what a chastity belt is.
这只是一个持续的设置。我觉得它太完美了。我想这就是为什么人们无法真正区分剧本和即兴表演的原因。它做得太完美了。我想问你关于那些餐厅场景的事。哦，是的。库珀餐厅（Coopers）。有一个关于贞操带的完整片段，他试图解释什么是贞操带。
Oh, my God. And you're like a chastity belt? I think the really fun part of their relationship is that it's always a surprise when, like, Holly's on board with him, with some joke. And then those moments like the chassis belt where she's so horrified. And yet, so forgiving. You know, here she is this, you know, she's still flirty with this guy and she likes him and not sure where it's going to go. But she's going to give that a pass. You know, always with Steve, it was so hard not to laugh.
哦，天哪。你说贞操带？我认为他们关系中真正有趣的部分是，当霍莉同意他的某个笑话时，总是令人惊讶。然后像贞操带那样的时刻，她感到如此震惊。然而，又如此宽容。你知道，在这里她，你知道，她仍然在和这个家伙调情，她喜欢他，不确定它会走向何方。但她会放过那个。你知道，总是和史蒂夫在一起，很难不笑。
It was also like a thrill that sets in. Look, I remember when I was 25, I went skydiving. And I did it where you're strapped to the other instructor. And just as the airplane door opened up and he made me look out, we were about, I guess, 13,000 feet near. And I remember the thought in my head is, okay, I'm going to die or I'm going to have the time of my life. Pick one. And I remember picking, I'm going to have fun. And as nervous as I was, you know, being like in those scenes with Steve, I remember that moment to like, oh, just pick one. Why don't you have fun instead? You know? And certainly with him at the lead, like, we're all going to look good. You know, he's going to take us along for the ride, I feel. But it was so hard not to laugh, like painfully hard to laugh.
这也像是一种刺激。看，我记得我 25 岁的时候，我去跳伞。我做的时候是绑在另一个教练身上。就在飞机门打开，他让我往外看的时候，我们大概在 13,000 英尺高空。我记得我脑子里的想法是，好吧，我要么死，要么度过我一生中最美好的时光。选一个。我记得我选了，我要玩得开心。尽管我很紧张，你知道，和史蒂夫一起演那些场景，我记得那一刻，哦，选一个。你为什么不玩得开心点呢？你知道？当然有他在前面带头，就像，我们看起来都会很好。你知道，他会带我们一起去兜风，我觉得。但这真的很难不笑，痛苦地难笑。
But I felt like we were dropped into another place of concentration that kind of pulled it all along, if that makes sense. Yeah. Did you know Steve before? Yeah. I had this minuscule part in Dan in real life that Steve starred in. It was this big extended family comedy. We all, is a whole group of us there on location in Rhode Island. And so we all became friends. And then I think it was about like six months after that film is when the office came up. And I believe they ran the idea by Steve of casting me. And I guess it helped. I knew him from Rhode Island for that little bit.
但我感觉我们被扔进了另一个专注的地方，这把一切都拉到了一起，如果这有意义的话。是的。你之前认识史蒂夫吗？是的。我在史蒂夫主演的《丹在生活中有个大麻烦》（Dan in Real Life）中有一个微不足道的角色。那是一部大型大家庭喜剧。我们都在，是一群人在罗德岛的外景地。所以我们都成了朋友。然后我想是在那部电影之后大概六个月，《办公室》就出现了。我相信他们把选我的想法告诉了史蒂夫。我想这有帮助。我因为那一点点戏份在罗德岛认识他。
Well, we always ask everyone if they have any like favorite memories from their time on the show, like any kind of behind the scenes moment or just something that you remember that stood out to you during your time on the office. Oh my gosh. There's so so much. I mean, just in a general note, I would honestly, no exaggeration, I would go home feeling like I worked out a series of sit-ups because my stomach muscles were always in play for laughing so hard. And I just go home, exhausted but happy. And that was a nice feeling. But there's, and speaking of that, like kind of the uncontrollable laughter, there's the episode where Darrell helps me move and he comes. in the car ride, the truck ride.
好吧，我们总是问每个人他们是否有任何像在节目中时光的珍贵记忆，比如任何幕后时刻，或者只是你记得在《办公室》期间让你印象深刻的事情。哦，天哪。有太多太多了。我的意思是，就一般而言，我老实说，毫不夸张，我会回家感觉像做了一系列仰卧起坐，因为我的腹肌总是因为笑得太厉害而处于运动状态。我只是回家，筋疲力尽但很开心。那是一种很好的感觉。但是有，说到那种，那种无法控制的笑声，有一集是达里尔（Darryl）帮我搬家，他来了。在车里，卡车里。
Yes, yeah. Me, Steve, and Craig, like, hold up in that truck all day. Kind of probably we had a little bit of lack of oxygen, but we couldn't, we just, we were in hysterics and could barely get through the scenes. And it was, that was like one of the highlights of my time there. I was just spending the day with those two guys, just laughing. I mean, I say that, but I'd also be on set and laughing all the time, too.
是的，是的。我和史蒂夫、克雷格（Craig）整天在那辆卡车里。可能我们有点缺氧，但我们无法，我们只是，我们笑得歇斯底里，几乎无法完成场景。那是我在那里的亮点之一。我只是和那两个家伙度过了一天，只是笑。我的意思是，我这么说，但我也会在片场，一直笑。
It was just very new to me. Usually I end up in these dramas where I'm crying all day. So this is a much better way to spend your day. I remember that, too, and I remember my agents asking me if I wanted to do dramas in my downtime. You mentioned you were like, I've done a lot of drama. is I want to do a comedy. Yeah. Like, do you want to take a stab at some drama?
这对我来说非常新鲜。通常我最终会出演那些我整天都在哭的剧情片。所以这是度过你一天更好的方式。我也记得那个，我记得我的经纪人问我是否想在空闲时间演剧情片。你提到你说，我演了很多剧情片。我想演一部喜剧。是的。你想尝试一些剧情片吗？
And I was like, I don't think so. I think I'm really liking the jobs where I just laugh all day. Because I'm like in a good mood a lot. So let's just, let's keep doing the comedies. It was, it was like, it was a happy place to work. My only request was if I could ever have a scene where I didn't frown. That's true. You had to frown your way through this comedy.
我说，我不这么认为。我想我真的很喜欢那些我整天都在笑的工作。因为我心情很好。所以让我们，让我们继续演喜剧。这就像，这是一个工作的好地方。我唯一的请求是，如果我能有一个我不皱眉的场景。那是真的。你必须在这部喜剧中皱着眉头演完。
Well, do you get recognized as Holly Flacks, like when you're out and about? Oh, I do. I do. And it's interesting. I'm sure I'm sure you guys have noticed that there's being recognized when the show was on the air. And then the whole streaming version of the show that has kind of taken it to a whole new level. And everyone's getting younger. Yeah.
好吧，你会被认作霍莉·弗拉克斯吗，比如当你外出时？哦，我会。我会。这很有趣。我相信你们肯定注意到了，当节目播出时被认出来。然后是整个流媒体版本的节目，它把它带到了一个全新的水平。每个人都变得越来越年轻。是的。
my daughter's friends. And so yeah, I do. I still get, I still get recognized. You know, years ago, not that long ago, a few years ago, my family and our really good friends, we went to Scranton because there's this amazing antique store called All Good Things. And it's just a warehouse, a giant warehouse of just every old antique knob, hinge, dresser, door. Toilet. Sign me up, Amy. It goes on forever.
我女儿的朋友。所以是的，我会。我仍然会被认出来。你知道，几年前，没过多久，几年前，我的家人和我们非常好的朋友，我们去了斯克兰顿（Scranton），因为有一家很棒的古董店叫“万事皆好”（All Good Things）。它只是一个仓库，一个巨大的仓库，里面有每一个旧的古董旋钮、铰链、梳妆台、门。马桶。算我一个，艾米。它没完没了。
It's really cool. And so we go there and then we're looking for something to eat and we're hungry. And they pull in and I was kind of behind the eight ball on this and we pull into Coopers. Oh my gosh. And I go, oh, no, no, no, you guys, no. I'm pretty, I mean, I don't get harassing, you know, but I'm pretty shy. If someone comes up to me on the street, I say hello and thank you. But I also have a lot of privacy.
真的很酷。所以我们去了那里，然后我们在找吃的，我们饿了。他们开进去了，我在这方面有点落后，我们开进了库珀餐厅。哦，天哪。我说，哦，不，不，不，你们，不。我相当，我的意思是，我不会被骚扰，你知道，但我很害羞。如果有人在街上走过来，我会说你好和谢谢。但我也很有隐私。
people don't always recognize me, but I was like, hell no, we are not going into Coopers. I am Polly from the office. I cannot walk into Coopers. I cannot. I cannot. I cannot. And my one friend, Anne was there, she's kind of naughty. She's like, oh, it'll be so good. We have to. We have to. So they talk me into it, but I go in and I've got my head down and I'm just like waiting. I'm waiting to be treated, you know, like the Beatles here or something. And we sit in a booth and this old tired waitress comes up and she takes our order. And my friend Anne right away, she's like, this is amazing. You know, what's the story here? She's like, oh, well, we've been here for X amount of years.
人们并不总是认出我，但我当时想，见鬼不，我们不去库珀餐厅。我是《办公室》里的霍莉。我不能走进库珀餐厅。我不能。我不能。我不能。我的一位朋友，安在那里，她有点淘气。她说，哦，那会很好。我们必须去。我们必须去。所以他们说服了我，但我进去了，我低着头，我只是在等。我在等被对待，你知道，像披头士乐队在这里之类的。我们坐在一个卡座里，一个疲惫的老女服务员走过来，她记下了我们的订单。我的朋友安立刻说，这太神奇了。你知道，这里有什么故事吗？她说，哦，好吧，我们在这里待了 X 年了。
And it was also used in the set of the office. But, you know, I mean, people used to be excited about that, but they're not anymore. What can I get you? I was like, so offended. Not one person recognized me. I know not one. Not one. And we left.
它也被用作《办公室》的片场。但是，你知道，我的意思是，人们过去对那个很兴奋，但他们现在不兴奋了。我能为你拿点什么？我当时觉得被冒犯了。没有一个人认出我。我知道没有一个。没有一个。我们离开了。
We gave her a good tip and we left. And I was like so so bummed. But anyway, that's my Cooper story. It's pretty cool inside, though. I think our set decoration did a pretty great job. The real Coopers is pretty cool. Yeah. Well, when people hear this podcast and they realize they might have been at Coopers with Holly Flax
我们给了她很好的小费，然后我们离开了。我当时觉得太沮丧了。但无论如何，这就是我的库珀故事。不过里面真的很酷。我认为我们的片场装饰做得很好。真正的库珀餐厅很酷。是的。好吧，当人们听到这个播客，他们意识到他们可能和霍莉·弗拉克斯在库珀餐厅
and didn't know it. they're going to be like, what day, what day? Oh, my God. It's part of like a whole Scranton, the office fan tour now. You know, they have like a whole tour and you can go around Scranton and go to all the spots. So maybe don't go back because maybe it will be the Beatles experience. Amy, before you, we're going to come on the podcast, I admit, I googled you, which is a weird thing to do. It's weird to Google someone you know.
却不知道。他们会说，哪一天，哪一天？哦，天哪。它现在是整个斯克兰顿，《办公室》粉丝之旅的一部分。你知道，他们有整个旅游，你可以绕着斯克兰顿走，去所有的景点。所以也许不要回去，因为也许它会成为披头士体验。艾米，在你，我们要来参加播客之前，我承认，我谷歌了你，这是一件奇怪的事情。谷歌你认识的人很奇怪。
It is so weird. It's so weird. And I, you know, had never done that before, Googled you. But I did. And I saw all of your stage work and stage experience, which I knew that you did theater, but I didn't know that you got your first touring job right out of school that you toured with Biloxi Blues. Right out of high school. Yeah.
这太奇怪了。这太奇怪了。而且，你知道，我以前从未那样做过，谷歌你。但我做了。我看到了你所有的舞台作品和舞台经验，我知道你演过戏剧，但我不知道你一毕业就得到了第一份巡演工作，你和《比洛克西蓝调》（Biloxi Blues）一起巡演。高中毕业后。是的。
So did you ever have like that day job? Did you ever have, or were you able to work pretty consistently as an actress right out of school? Yeah, so I went to a performing arts high school in New York, and then a month or so after graduation, I was cast in the touring company of Blexi Blues, and I toured for nine months and thought, well, that's easy. I'll work all the time, I guess. I didn't work for a long time afterwards, but I, after the tour, I was still only like 18, 19, so, you know, I went back home, so I didn't have rent. I was still, you know, my family, we lived in New York, so I was able to afford a life in New York by just being an actor and doing acting jobs until I moved out of the house in my mid-30s. I know, but I, no, yeah, I'm very, I'm very lucky.
所以你有没有过那种日常工作？你有没有过，或者你能够一毕业就作为演员相当稳定地工作？是的，所以我去了纽约的一所表演艺术高中，然后毕业一个月左右，我就被选入了《比洛克西蓝调》的巡演公司，我巡演了九个月，心想，好吧，那很容易。我想我会一直工作。之后很长一段时间我都没有工作，但我，巡演后，我才 18、19 岁，所以，你知道，我回家了，所以我没有房租。我仍然，你知道，我的家人，我们住在纽约，所以我能够通过做演员和演戏工作来负担在纽约的生活，直到我 30 多岁搬出家门。我知道，但我，不，是的，我很幸运。
I had, I've only ever been an actor, save before high school graduation. I worked in my aunt and uncle's ice cream shop in Vermont when I was 16. But, yeah, acting's been my only job. That's amazing. It's kind of weird. But I, you know, I do think of how any young actor artist moves to L.A., moves to New York from other places or, you know, to Chicago with, I always think of that person like suitcase in hand.
我只做过演员，除了高中毕业前。我 16 岁时在佛蒙特州我阿姨和叔叔的冰淇淋店工作过。但是，是的，演戏一直是我唯一的工作。这太神奇了。这有点奇怪。但我，你知道，我确实想到任何年轻的演员艺术家如何搬到洛杉矶，从其他地方搬到纽约，或者，你知道，带着行李箱去芝加哥，我总是想到那个人，行李箱在手。
and, you know, room share lists. Like my hat just goes off to them because it's so hard. It's so hard. I don't know how people do it. You know, I was lucky that I already lived in New York and could go home for home-cooked meals and all that kind of stuff. But I'm glad they're doing it somehow. Are you working on anything now, Amy?
而且，你知道，合租名单。就像我的帽子向他们致敬，因为这太难了。这太难了。我不知道人们是怎么做到的。你知道，我很幸运，我已经住在纽约，可以回家吃家常菜之类的东西。但我很高兴他们以某种方式做到了。艾米，你现在在做什么吗？
I just finished this new first season of this Hulu series called Only Murders in the Building with Steve Martin. and Martin Short and Selena Gomez. And it was, again, like, it was a throwback to, like, again, Jen, like you say, like doing the comedy, like, oh, this feels fun. I'm in a good mood. And certainly shooting through a pandemic, you know, it was, I wouldn't want to be on a heavy drama right now.
我刚刚完成了这部 Hulu 系列剧《大楼里只有谋杀案》（Only Murders in the Building）的第一季，和史蒂夫·马丁（Steve Martin）、马丁·肖特（Martin Short）和赛琳娜·戈麦斯（Selena Gomez）一起。而且，再次，就像，这是对，再次，珍娜，就像你说的那样，演喜剧，就像，哦，这感觉很有趣。我心情很好。当然，在疫情期间拍摄，你知道，我不想现在演一部沉重的剧情片。
It's just too intense. But it was a joy to be around those people during this time. So, but that's it. And I don't know, I don't know what I'll do next, that, you know, even after 33 years, like, I never know what's next. So I'll see what happens. Well, Amy, thank you so much for coming on office ladies and sharing your memories of being on the show. It was so cool to be back in touch with you and see you again. Oh, same here. I really miss you guys. And I hope all so well with your families and I hope to see you in person. Yes, that would be amazing. Jen and I have said we want to do like an office ladies lunch, like call up all the gown, have a lunch. Wouldn't that be so fun? Yeah.
这太紧张了。但在那个时候和那些人在一起是一种快乐。所以，但就是这样。我不知道，我不知道接下来我会做什么，那，你知道，即使在 33 年之后，就像，我永远不知道接下来会发生什么。所以我会看看会发生什么。好吧，艾米，非常感谢你来到“办公室女士”并分享你在节目中的记忆。能再次与你联系并见到你真是太酷了。哦，我也是。我真的很想念你们。我希望你们的家人一切都好，我希望亲自见到你们。是的，那会很棒。珍娜和我说过我们想做一次“办公室女士”午餐，就像叫上所有的演员，吃顿午餐。那不是很有趣吗？是的。
Oh, gosh. Well, let's do it. Let's do it. Thank you so much, Amy. Thanks for having me on your show. I miss you all. And let's hope to see you soon. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp.
哦，天哪。好吧，我们做吧。我们做吧。非常感谢你，艾米。谢谢你邀请我参加你的节目。我想念你们所有人。让我们希望很快见到你们。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。
You know, we are going to take a moment to celebrate women and all that they carry at work, in relationships, and families. and in the many roles they hold every single day. And we need to remind ourselves about how much we matter and that therapy offers a space for us to take care of ourselves in the way we deserve. Therapy can also be a place to set boundaries and build confidence. Just take care of your own well-being for a change. BetterHelp makes therapy accessible and flexible. Their therapists are fully licensed in the U.S. and follow a strict code of conduct. With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform, and it works, with an average rating of 4.9 out of five for a live session based on over 1.7 million client reviews. Your emotional well-being matters.
你知道，我们要花点时间来庆祝女性以及她们在工作中、人际关系和家庭中承担的一切。以及她们每天扮演的许多角色。我们需要提醒自己我们有多重要，治疗为我们提供了一个空间，让我们以我们应得的方式照顾自己。治疗也可以是一个设定界限和建立自信的地方。为了改变，照顾好你自己的幸福。BetterHelp 让治疗变得可及且灵活。他们的治疗师在美国完全获得许可，并遵守严格的行为准则。拥有超过 30,000 名治疗师，BetterHelp 是世界上最大的在线治疗平台，而且它有效，基于超过 170 万条客户评论，现场会议的平均评分为 4.9 分（满分 5 分）。你的情感健康很重要。
Find support and feel lighter in therapy. Sign up and get 10% off at betterhelp.com slash office ladies. That's better help.com slash office ladies. Hi, it's me. Jesse Tyler Ferguson. In case you haven't heard, and I don't know how that's possible, you're obviously not seeing my Instagram stories, but I have a podcast. I know, I know, I know. I didn't think there was enough podcasts, especially podcasts hosted by actors. So here I am. It's called Dinner's On Me, and it's actually pretty special to me. It combines two things that I absolutely love, eating and connecting with people. So in each episode, I take an old friend or a friend. new friend, out to a fabulous meal, and as we break bread, we dive into everything from imposter syndrome and mental health to being a new parent, navigating new relationships. It's fun because you truly get to be a fly on the wall for some really intimate conversations. So please, pull up a chair, join us. You can listen to Dinners on Me, wherever you get your podcasts.
在BetterHelp寻求心理咨询，让心情更轻松。注册并访问betterhelp.com/officeladies可享受九折优惠。网址是betterhelp.com/officeladies。嗨，是我，杰西·泰勒·弗格森。如果你还没听说——我不知道这怎么可能，显然你没看我的Instagram快拍——但我有个播客。我知道，我知道，我知道。我本以为播客已经够多了，尤其是演员主持的播客。但我就在这儿。它叫《Dinner's On Me》，对我来说真的很特别。它结合了我绝对热爱的两件事：美食和与人交流。所以，在每一集里，我都会带一位老朋友或新朋友去吃一顿美餐。在用餐时，我们会深入探讨各种话题，从冒名顶替综合症和心理健康，到为人父母和处理新的人际关系。这很有趣，因为你真的能像墙上的苍蝇一样，旁听一些非常私密的对话。所以，请拉把椅子加入我们吧。你可以在任何收听播客的地方收听《Dinner's On Me》。
I was so great. I love her. I love her. You know, when we got finished with that interview, you guys, I asked her what color were her walls because her room it was like painted all this like kind of dark blue gray color. Kind of a navy blue. It's very cozy looking. I know.
她太棒了。我爱她。我爱她。你知道吗，我们采访结束后，我问她墙是什么颜色的，因为她的房间漆成了一种深蓝灰色。有点像海军蓝。看起来非常温馨。我知道。
And she's in a red dress and her hair was perfect. I kind of want to get that bob. I don't know if I can pull it off. It was such a cute bob. It was. Well, you know, obviously we're going to put photos from our zoomy zoom in the Instagram. Yeah. So you can see it all.
她穿着红裙子，发型也很完美。我有点想剪那个波波头。我不知道我能不能驾驭。那真是个可爱的波波头。确实。嗯，你知道，我们肯定会把Zoom视频里的照片发到Instagram上。是的。这样你就能看到了。
The wall, the bob, it's coming at you. Okay. Before we get into this episode, I need to share with you who was on. the DVD commentary. Oh. But I'm going to let B.J. tell you. What? Welcome to the commentary on business ethics.
墙壁、波波头，马上就来。好了。在进入这一集之前，我需要告诉你们谁参与了DVD评论录音。哦。但我会让B.J.来告诉你们。什么？欢迎收看《商务道德》的评论。
This is B.J. Novak speaking, and this is a very special commentary because I have with me here. Four of the most beloved crew members on the office to give us a behind-the-scenes look at how things go, not just with this episode, but every day for the past 100 episodes. So, seated with me. Why don't we make introductions from my left? Bartankchirian Peter Evangelatos Sergio Zucumann
我是B.J.诺瓦克，这是一次非常特别的评论录音，因为我身边有四位《办公室》最受喜爱的剧组成员，他们将带我们了解幕后故事，不仅是这一集，还有过去100集里的每一天。所以，坐在我身边的是……我们从左边开始介绍吧？瓦尔坦·奇里安、彼得·埃万杰拉托斯、塞尔吉奥·祖库曼。
Alan Mork And here's how it works I know Oh my God I know I know I had the same reaction And their voices are on the whole thing Yes
艾伦·莫克。事情就是这样。我知道。天哪，我知道，我知道。我的反应也一样。他们的声音贯穿了整个过程。是的。
Oh my goodness I did not think that's I know I know I texted BJ I said BJ I have teared up I have laughed I've had every emotion
天哪，我没想到会是这样。我知道，我知道。我给B.J.发了短信，我说：“B.J.，我流泪了，我笑了，我经历了各种情绪。”
Oh guys Okay we should say who they are Okay, so Peter and Vartan, they did our craft services. They provided the cast and crew with snacks, drinks, meals, anything that you could want, and fed us in overtime. We called them the snack masters. Peter was so beloved to us. He was like our grandpa. Yeah. And he took such good care of us. He passed away a few years ago. Our cast and crew were heartbroken. We loved this man. And it was a delight to get to you. hear his voice in this DVD commentary, I felt like I spent, you know, an evening with him when I rewatched it and I texted BJ immediately. And he said, oh, my God, Angela, where is this? Where can I hear it? Where does it live? He said, I'm so happy it made you happy. He said, I'm so happy it exists. And he said that he pitched that Peter and Vartan and Sergio and Allen do this commentary. And people were like, what? No, you're crazy. But he was like, you know, like they are.
哦，伙计们。好吧，我们应该说说他们是谁。好吧，彼得和瓦尔坦负责我们的餐饮服务。他们为演员和剧组提供零食、饮料、餐点，任何你想要的，甚至在加班时也喂饱我们。我们称他们为“零食大师”。彼得深受我们喜爱。他就像我们的爷爷。是的。他非常照顾我们。他几年前去世了。我们的演员和剧组都心碎了。我们爱这个男人。能在DVD评论里听到他的声音真是太好了，重看的时候感觉就像和他度过了一个晚上。我立刻给B.J.发了短信，他说：“天哪，安吉拉，这是在哪儿？我在哪儿能听到？它存在于哪里？”他说他很高兴这让我感到快乐。他说他很高兴它存在。他说他提议让彼得、瓦尔坦、塞尔吉奥和艾伦做这个评论录音时，人们说：“什么？不，你疯了。”但他觉得他们就是……
Like our sustenance, they took such good care of us. We should say, Sergio and Ellen, they were big time catering, and they fed us lunch and breakfast. They did our big main meals. Yeah. Breakfast and lunch. And Peter and Vartan did everything in between. Yeah. And I really want to share with you what all they talked about on the DVD commentary.
就像我们的补给，他们非常照顾我们。我们应该说，塞尔吉奥和艾伦负责大型餐饮，他们为我们提供午餐和早餐。他们负责我们的大餐。是的。早餐和午餐。而彼得和瓦尔坦负责中间的一切。是的。我真的很想和你们分享他们在DVD评论里谈论的所有内容。
Oh, yeah. They talked about food the whole entire episode. I learned nothing about the actual episode. but I learned what everyone has for breakfast in people's particular request. And it was so delightful. And I think the office fans are going to love this. You've got to say, you have to share. Okay, okay, here we go.
哦，是的。他们整集都在谈论食物。关于这一集本身我什么都没学到，但我知道了每个人早餐吃什么，以及大家的特殊要求。这太令人愉快了。我想《办公室》的粉丝们会喜欢的。你一定要说，你一定要分享。好吧，好吧，我们开始吧。
And then I promise we will get to business ethics, you guys. Okay. First of all, we love people's process. How is their day started? What do they do? Sergio and Alan shared that they got to set, very, very early. Well, we knew this. I looked up our call sheets. You guys know I have digital clutter. I have all of our call sheets for years. Yeah. Average cast call time started at 5 a.m.
然后我保证我们会进入《商务道德》的话题，伙计们。好吧。首先，我们喜欢人们的习惯。他们的一天是怎么开始的？他们做什么？塞尔吉奥和艾伦分享说他们到片场非常非常早。嗯，我们知道这一点。我查了我们的通告单。你们知道我有数字杂物。我有多年来所有的通告单。是的。演员的平均通告时间是早上5点。
That meant hair and makeup had to be there at 4 a.m. That meant that Sergio and Alan had to have a full breakfast ready at 4 a.m. Wow. So they would go to bed at 7 p.m. and get up between midnight and 1 a.m. to be at work at 2 a.m. to start cooking. Alan said every morning I was cooking bacon at 3.m.000. a.m. And they kind of joked that he was like Michael Scott. He like woke up and had to start cooking bacon. But you know, they fed breakfast to around 150 people. Yep, because the crew got a hot breakfast. Yeah, everybody, everybody, cast and crew. Sergio and Allen, like, BJ would just mention someone's name and they knew their breakfast order. Oh, say. Okay. Ready? Yeah. Steve would have mushrooms, ground turkey, egg white scramble with a side of ketchup. Okay. Rain would have a veggie scramble
这意味着发型和化妆必须在凌晨4点到达。这意味着塞尔吉奥和艾伦必须在凌晨4点准备好丰盛的早餐。哇。所以他们会在晚上7点睡觉，在午夜到凌晨1点之间起床，凌晨2点到岗开始做饭。艾伦说每天早上我都在凌晨3点煎培根。他们开玩笑说他就像迈克尔·斯科特。他醒来就得开始煎培根。但你知道，他们为大约150人提供早餐。是的，因为剧组有热早餐。是的，每个人，演员和剧组。塞尔吉奥和艾伦，就像B.J.只要提到某人的名字，他们就知道他们的早餐订单。哦，说吧。好吧，准备好了吗？是的。史蒂夫会吃蘑菇、火鸡肉末、蛋白炒蛋，配一点番茄酱。好吧。雷恩会吃蔬菜炒蛋。
with egg whites and one piece of wheat toast. Jenna, yes, would have two egg whites scrambled with a little bit of cheese. That's true. Paul Lieberstein would have an egg white scramble with onions and peppers with Sergio's famous homemade salsa on the side. We weren't very into egg whites as a cast. I'm discovering.
配蛋白和一片全麦吐司。珍娜，是的，会吃两个蛋白炒蛋，加一点奶酪。那是真的。保罗·利伯斯坦会吃蛋白炒蛋，加洋葱和辣椒，配上塞尔吉奥著名的自制莎莎酱。我发现我们作为演员不太喜欢蛋白。
Keep it coming. Kate had egg white scramble with turkey bacon. Oscar, curveball, grilled cheese with tomato. Amy Ryan, who's our guest this week, spinach and egg scramble. Now, some cast members had their breakfast order become classics because they became so popular. Okay. Okay? So you could order these three.
继续说。凯特吃蛋白炒蛋配火鸡培根。奥斯卡，出人意料，烤奶酪三明治配番茄。艾米·瑞恩，我们这周的嘉宾，菠菜炒蛋。现在，一些演员的早餐订单成了经典，因为它们太受欢迎了。好吧。好吧？所以你可以点这三种。
We've already discussed the Rashida special. Yes. Remember, invented by Rashida, Black Beans, Turkey Bacon, Avocado, Egg Whites, Sergio Sosa, Two Corn Tittias on the side. All right. That's a Rashida. It was the most popular. Okay. Okay.
我们已经讨论过“拉什达特制”了。是的。记得吗，拉什达发明的，黑豆、火鸡培根、牛油果、蛋白、塞尔吉奥莎莎酱，配两片玉米饼。好了。这就是“拉什达”。它是最受欢迎的。好吧。好吧。
The Rashida is special. Rishita, inventing the most popular breakfast. In fact, it was like one of Mindy's regular orders was the Rashida. Okay. The Johnny Kaye invented by John Kresensky. Tomatoes and broccoli with egg whites and a little cheddar cheese. Hmm. Sounds right.
“拉什达”是特制的。拉什达发明了最受欢迎的早餐。事实上，明迪的常点餐之一就是“拉什达”。好吧。约翰·卡拉辛斯基发明的“约翰尼·凯”。番茄和西兰花配蛋白和一点切达干酪。嗯。听起来不错。
I know. Kind of gross. I don't want to eat broccoli first thing in the morning. I don't know. I'm not going to lie. There were, you know, a few times I would cross over here and make up with John. It didn't smell good. It's coming back to me now.
我知道。有点恶心。我不想一大早就吃西兰花。我不知道。我不撒谎。有几次我会在化妆时遇到约翰。味道不好。现在想起来了。
It doesn't smell good. Okay, the Creed special. I learned something. Creed is apparently a big goat cheese fan. He loves goat cheese. In the morning? Oh, yeah. So they said that he would have goat cheese, spinach, onions, and egg whites with green tea.
味道不好。好吧，“克里德特制”。我学到了一件事。克里德显然是个山羊奶酪迷。他喜欢山羊奶酪。在早上？哦，是的。所以他们说他会吃山羊奶酪、菠菜、洋葱和蛋白，配绿茶。
Oh. Mm-hmm. They also shared the two cast members who were always there the earliest. Oh, let me guess. Okay. Kate and Phyllis. Leslie and Phyllis. Okay. And, you know, I looked at the call sheets. Leslie, Phyllis, me, and Kate were always called in at 5 a.m. Okay? The four of us. I clearly didn't make the early list. But Leslie would order his breakfast at 445. Wow. Yeah. Sergio and Allen also did a huge lunch with multiple meat, fish, veggie choices, salad bar, dessert bar. But they said there was one item they featured just on a whim at the dessert table. And it became incredibly popular. And if they wouldn't have it, people would.
哦。嗯。他们还分享了两个总是最早到的演员。哦，让我猜猜。好吧。凯特和菲利斯。莱斯利和菲利斯。好吧。而且，你知道，我看了通告单。莱斯利、菲利斯、我和凯特总是被要求在早上5点到达。好吧？我们四个。我显然没进早到名单。但莱斯利会在4点45分点早餐。哇。是的。塞尔吉奥和艾伦还提供丰盛的午餐，有多种肉类、鱼类、蔬菜选择、沙拉吧、甜点吧。但他们说甜点桌上有一项他们一时兴起推出的甜点，变得非常受欢迎。如果他们不提供，人们会……
would like get like annoyed. They'd be like, where is it? Can I guess? Yeah. Was it the warm chocolate chip cookie bar things? Yes. Yes. It was the chocolate chip cookie cake. And they served it like hot and melted and kind of gooey.
会感到恼火。他们会说：“它在哪儿？”我可以猜吗？是的。是那个热巧克力曲奇饼块吗？是的。是的。那是巧克力曲奇蛋糕。他们把它热着端上来，融化了，有点黏糊糊的。
It was so good. You guys, the chocolate chip cookie cake was Steve Corel's like kryptonite? I don't know. This guy would eat so healthy, but he had to eat this chocolate chip cookie cake. This is one treat. But literally they said they didn't think. much about it. They made it one time. And then everyone was like, where is it? Where is it? They had to make it like every day. Yeah. So now I have to talk about Peter and Vartan. They were the snack masters.
太好吃了。伙计们，巧克力曲奇蛋糕就像史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的“氪石”？我不知道。这家伙吃得非常健康，但他必须吃这个巧克力曲奇蛋糕。这是一种享受。但他们说他们真的没多想。他们做了一次。然后每个人都问：“它在哪儿？它在哪儿？”他们不得不每天都做。是的。所以现在我得谈谈彼得和瓦尔坦。他们是“零食大师”。
They had kind of like a full kitchen right on the set, right outside the Dundermifflin bullpen. Yep. You know, they had a fridge. You could have cereal. They had milk. You could make your own sandwich. But they would also have a little food bar. And here's what they had to share. Peter talked about how he had been in the business forever. He also said, I thought this was kind of funny, At our cast, we were tea obsessed. He had hundreds of different types of teas. And you might have noticed that I didn't make Sergio and Allen's breakfast list. Because you would never eat an egg in the morning. Because Peter and Vartan got donuts every morning.
他们在片场有一个完整的厨房，就在邓德·米夫林办公室外面。是的。你知道，他们有一个冰箱。你可以吃麦片。他们有牛奶。你可以自己做三明治。但他们也有一个小食品吧。这是他们要分享的。彼得谈到他已经在这一行待了很久了。他还说，我觉得这很有趣，我们的演员对茶很着迷。他有数百种不同的茶。你可能注意到我没进塞尔吉奥和艾伦的早餐名单。因为你早上绝不会吃鸡蛋。因为彼得和瓦尔坦每天早上都有甜甜圈。
So I would go get a donut from Peter and Vartan. Also, BJ liked the Porto's coffee cake. And then Peter said, sometimes he would make you and I sandwiches. He would. And he said he loved doing it and he would put them on a porcelain plate and bring them to us. I'm crying again. I know. I know. He took such good care of us. I can't explain to you like the care with which he would make us a sandwich. It's so silly and simple, but he would. He'd put it on a porcelain plate and he'd always like garnish it with some cute little like fruit or like a little pickles.
所以我去彼得和瓦尔坦那儿拿甜甜圈。另外，B.J.喜欢波尔图的咖啡蛋糕。然后彼得说，有时他会为你和我做三明治。他会做的。他说他很喜欢这样做，他会把它们放在瓷盘上端给我们。我又哭了。我知道。我知道。他非常照顾我们。我无法向你解释他为我们做三明治时的那种用心。这很傻很简单，但他会做的。他会把它放在瓷盘上，总是用一些可爱的小水果或小酸黄瓜装饰它。
into a shape. Yeah. It really was. It was like your grandpa made you a sandwich. It really was. And you felt so love. He was so happy to do it. Yeah.
做成某种形状。是的。真的。就像你爷爷给你做三明治一样。确实是。你感到被爱。他很高兴这样做。是的。
He said that he would make you a tuna fish sandwich. Mm-hmm. And he'd make me ham and cheese. I cried through this commentary, Jenna. I laughed so hard because Peter and Vartan give each other like such a hard time lovingly. And they're so funny. Alan called him the Middle Eastern odd couple. Because Peter is from Greece and Vartan is from Iraq.
他说他会为你做金枪鱼三明治。嗯。他会给我做火腿奶酪三明治。我在这次评论录音中哭了，珍娜。我笑得太厉害了，因为彼得和瓦尔坦互相开玩笑，充满爱意。他们太搞笑了。艾伦称他们为“中东版的老友记”。因为彼得来自希腊，瓦尔坦来自伊拉克。
They had a hilarious banter, the two of them. They also talked about their infamous 10 a.m. hot snack. Hot snack. Oh my gosh. Peter said they like to mix it up every day. He said on Mondays, for example, there'd be tacos and burritos. One of the most popular hot snack items was albondaga soup. Well, they talked about that, but they said they're turkey chili.
他们俩有非常滑稽的互动。他们还谈到了他们臭名昭著的上午10点热点心。热点心。天哪。彼得说他们喜欢每天换花样。他说，例如周一，会有塔可和卷饼。最受欢迎的热点心之一是阿尔邦迪加汤。嗯，他们谈到了那个，但他们说他们的火鸡辣椒酱。
Oh. They said they're turkey chili. They had to serve twice a week. People wanted it. They loved it. Ed Helms in particular, love the turkey chili, and he came up with a little tip. What is it? Ed, you know, they had garnishes on the side for the chili.
哦。他们说他们的火鸡辣椒酱。他们必须一周供应两次。人们想要它。他们很喜欢。尤其是艾德·赫尔姆斯，他喜欢火鸡辣椒酱，他想出了一个小窍门。是什么？艾德，你知道，他们有配菜。
They had shredded cheese and they had onions. Ed would put the raw onions at the bottom of his bowl, add the hot turkey chili on top, and the heat from the chili would caramelize the onions at the bottom. Wow. It became a thing. So, and much like our Dundermifling counterparts, they said the cast and crew had their favorite pizza places to order from, if we went to overtime and we got second meal. Steve loved Mulberry's pizza.
他们有碎奶酪和洋葱。艾德会把生洋葱放在碗底，加上热的火鸡辣椒酱，辣椒酱的热度会把底部的洋葱焦糖化。哇。这成了一件事。所以，就像我们的邓德·米夫林同事一样，他们说演员和剧组有他们最喜欢的披萨店，如果我们加班并吃了第二顿饭的话。史蒂夫喜欢桑伯里披萨。
Mm-hmm. And we all loved Barone's pizza. Yes. It was a delight, you guys. I just have to tell you, we loved these men so much. I was lucky enough to work with Sergio again when I guest started on Mindy's show, Never Have I Ever. She still wants Sergio on her projects.
嗯。我们都喜欢巴隆披萨。是的。这真是一种享受，伙计们。我必须告诉你们，我们非常爱这些人。我有幸在明迪的节目《好想做一次》客串时再次与塞尔吉奥合作。她仍然想让塞尔吉奥参与她的项目。
It was so awesome. These guys were our family. Yeah. And they took such good care of us. And if you have ever wondered why the only thing my dad talked about was the food, when he visited set. Listen to this commentary. I loved that.
太棒了。这些人是我们的家人。是的。他们非常照顾我们。如果你曾经好奇为什么我爸爸参观片场时唯一谈论的就是食物。听听这个评论录音吧。我喜欢那个。
I loved it too. And I know I went on and on, but I had to share it. I hope everyone else found it interesting because I loved that trip down memory lane. Thank you, Angela. You're welcome. All right. Shall we get into this episode? I guess we can.
我也喜欢。我知道我没完没了，但我必须分享它。我希望其他人也觉得有趣，因为我喜欢那次回忆之旅。谢谢你，安吉拉。不客气。好了。我们要进入这一集了吗？我想我们可以。
I will pull myself together. Yes. This episode starts with Jim and Pam on the phone. Pam is kind of mad because nobody congratulated her on her engagement. engagement. And Jim says, yeah, I don't tell anyone. And then he's like, let's tell him. And he puts Pam on speakerphone. And it goes, I think exactly how Jim thought it would go. Yeah. It ends with Michael arriving and hearing the news and tackling Jim to the floor. We got a fan question from Kyle T. and Peyton M. How was the stunt done where Michael knocks Jim over with a hug? Also, John's face is just
我会振作起来的。是的。这一集以吉姆和帕姆在电话里开始。帕姆有点生气，因为没人祝贺她订婚。订婚。吉姆说，是的，我没告诉任何人。然后他说，我们告诉他们吧。他把帕姆设为免提。我想结果和吉姆想的一模一样。是的。结局是迈克尔赶到，听到消息，把吉姆扑倒在地。我们收到了凯尔·T和佩顿·M的粉丝提问。迈克尔拥抱扑倒吉姆的特技是怎么完成的？还有，约翰的表情简直……
amazing. You know, that is a really hard thing to do to know you're going to be tackled, but keep your body relaxed. And not like wits. Yeah. Not expect the tackle. Well, I wasn't there. I was backstage on a phone, so I didn't see it go down. Angela, do you remember, was there like a mattress or something that they landed on? There is a big blue squishy thing. You know what I mean? A big blue square. It looked like a gymnastics kind of mat, right? Yeah. But it was so funny. I have to imagine. John lost it because John did not do well in scenes like that, especially with Steve. I don't. My memory of it is they didn't do it very many times. Okay. Well, now we're into the episode. It's Ethics Day. Holly has passed out a form. Everyone has to fill out. She's going to be taking this seriously.
太棒了。你知道，知道自己要被扑倒，但保持身体放松是一件很难的事。不像……是的。不要预料到扑倒。嗯，我不在那儿。我在后台打电话，所以我没看到那一幕。安吉拉，你记得吗，他们着陆的地方有垫子之类的东西吗？有一个大的蓝色软垫。你知道我的意思吗？一个大的蓝色方块。看起来像体操垫，对吧？是的。但这太搞笑了。我得想象一下。约翰笑场了，因为约翰在那种场景中表现不好，尤其是和史蒂夫在一起时。我不……我的记忆是他们没拍多少次。好吧。好吧，现在我们进入这一集了。今天是道德日。霍莉发了一张表格。每个人都必须填写。她会认真对待这件事。
She is. She explains that she is going to be running her first meeting. But don't worry. We talked about this with Amy Ryan. Michael's going to help her out. And they're going to start it off with their version of let's get physical. With headbands and dancing and a boombox. Jenna, I worked in corporate America. I have been in Human Resources seminars that we had to go to. I'm telling you they had skits. What?
她是。她解释说她要主持她的第一次会议。但别担心。我们和艾米·瑞恩谈过这个。迈克尔会帮她。他们会用他们的《Let's Get Physical》版本开场。戴着头带，跳着舞，拿着收音机。珍娜，我在企业界工作过。我参加过我们必须去的各种人力资源研讨会。我告诉你，他们有短剧。什么？
When I watched this, I had such a flood of memories coming back of sitting in a tiny little conference room. when I worked at this company. And our Human Resources Department, there were two people. They would come in and act out skits of what's inappropriate. We had one guy, his name was Tom, and we had a gal. Her name was Susan. And he'd be like, Susan, that skirt looks really nice on you today. Hey, time to party.
当我看到这一幕时，我脑海中涌现出许多回忆，坐在一个小会议室里。当我在那家公司工作时。我们的人力资源部有两个人。他们会进来表演短剧，演示什么是不得体的。我们有一个叫汤姆的家伙，还有一个叫苏珊的女孩。他会说：“苏珊，那条裙子今天穿在你身上真好看。嘿，派对时间到了。”
And then Susan would do a face like, huh? And then they'd freeze. And then Tom would say, what was inappropriate in this moment? And we'd all have to raise our hands and be like, He was kind of gross about her skirt. I only had to watch, like, produced videos of weird things. I've never seen a live presentation. Oh, no.
然后苏珊会做一个表情，像“哈？”然后他们会定格。然后汤姆会说：“这一刻有什么不得体的地方？”我们都得举手说：“他对她的裙子评价很恶心。”我只看过那种制作好的关于奇怪事情的视频。我从没见过现场演示。哦，不。
I watched skits. We had a fan question about this scene. We did. From Patricia B. She said, I'm wondering if some of the younger office fans even know the song that Holly and Michael are performing. She wants to know, Angela, did your kids watch this one with you? Did you have to explain the song parody? Isabel watched it with me.
我看了短剧。我们有一个关于这一幕的粉丝提问。我们有。来自帕特里夏·B。她说：“我想知道一些年轻的《办公室》粉丝是否知道霍莉和迈克尔表演的那首歌。”她想知道，安吉拉，你的孩子们和你一起看这一集了吗？你必须解释那首歌的戏仿吗？伊莎贝尔和我一起看了。
She didn't ask about the song. She thought it was funny. She probably thinks we made it up. Yeah, this was, I guess, for our younger listeners, a very famous song by Olivia Newton-John. Let's Get Physical. And the music video was like her in like an aerobics class singing and dancing with a headband. Jane Fonda had like these workout videos at the time too. This was like a little trend.
她没问那首歌。她觉得很有趣。她可能以为是我们编的。是的，对于我们年轻的听众来说，这是奥利维亚·纽顿-约翰的一首非常著名的歌，《Let's Get Physical》。音乐录影带里她就像在一个健美操班里唱歌跳舞，戴着头带。简·方达当时也有这种健身视频。这就像一个小潮流。
Sexy working out. But your sexy workout included tights, leg warmers, high tops, leotard, headband, wristband. Yeah. It was a whole thing. It was. I remember it well. Well, Holly begins her ethics meeting by explaining that there's been some misconduct. She's clearly talking about Ryan.
性感的锻炼。但你的性感锻炼包括紧身裤、护腿、高帮鞋、连体衣、头带、护腕。是的。这整件事。确实。我记得很清楚。嗯，霍莉开始她的道德会议，解释说发生了一些不当行为。她显然是在说瑞安。
Who's been hired again? It's so hilarious to me. Yeah. I know. And then she starts going through the results of the quits. Yeah, pretty much. She's got this binder. Yeah. And she's got to go through the binder. The HR binder. Yeah. We had a fan question from Peyton M. In the conference room scene, did Creed and Meredith actually break when Stanley said the meeting was a waste of time or was it scripted for them to laugh? While I looked at the script, it was scripted. The script said, people laugh a lot. That was the. direction in the script. So the meeting isn't going so great. And Michael's like, you're losing them. Yeah. She pulls Holly aside. You are losing them. They expect a lot. Yeah, it's really sweet.
他又被雇用了？这对我来说太搞笑了。是的。我知道。然后她开始过一遍辞职的结果。是的，差不多。她有这个活页夹。是的。她得过一遍活页夹。人力资源活页夹。是的。我们有一个来自佩顿·M的粉丝提问。在会议室场景中，当斯坦利说会议是在浪费时间时，克里德和梅雷迪思是真的笑场了，还是剧本让他们笑？我查了剧本，那是剧本写的。剧本说：“人们笑得很厉害。”那是剧本里的导演要求。所以会议进行得不太顺利。迈克尔说：“你正在失去他们。”是的。他把霍莉拉到一边。“你正在失去他们。他们期望很高。”是的，这真的很贴心。
He's trying to help her in this meeting because he really wants her to succeed. So he says, let's get rid of the binder. This is your opportunity to speak up without any repercussions. He's like, guys, what are some things maybe you've done at work to waste time? What have you? to anything or anything you want to share. Yeah, you have immunity. Go for it. Well, during this time, Michael confesses that he didn't work for five days when he discovered YouTube. It made me laugh so hard. He said he watched Cookie Monster sings Chocolate Rain about a thousand times. Did you go watch it? I had to know. Of course. Here's the thing. What? Chocolate Rain, according to its Wikipedia page, was a song by American singer,
他试图在这次会议上帮助她，因为他真的希望她成功。所以他说，扔掉活页夹吧。这是你们在没有任何后果的情况下发言的机会。他说：“伙计们，你们在工作中浪费时间做过什么事吗？你们有什么想分享的吗？”是的，你们有豁免权。尽管说吧。嗯，在这期间，迈克尔承认他发现YouTube后有五天没工作。这让我笑得太厉害了。他说他看了大约一千遍《饼干怪兽唱巧克力雨》。你去看了吗？我必须知道。当然。事情是这样的。什么？《巧克力雨》，根据维基百科页面，是一首美国歌手唱的歌，
Tay Zonde. I went and watched Tays last night. Oh, you did? I did. You watched it as well. Yeah. Yes. So he wrote this song and he uploaded a video to YouTube. It was four minutes, 52 seconds long. He uploaded it, everyone, because I know you want to know, April 22nd,
泰·宗德。我昨晚去看了泰的视频。哦，你看了？我看了。你也看了。是的。是的。所以他写了这首歌，并上传了一个视频到YouTube。它有4分52秒长。每个人，因为我知道你们想知道，他上传于4月22日，
2007. I remember it went viral. Viral. Like before things went viral. It was ranked the hottest viral video of summer 2007 and it was awarded the 2008 YouTube Award. in the category of music. So this song then became the subject of like parodies, remixes, tributes. It was everywhere.
2007年。我记得它火了。病毒式传播。在事情变得病毒式传播之前。它被评为2007年夏天最热门的病毒视频，并获得了2008年YouTube音乐类奖项。所以这首歌后来成了戏仿、混音、致敬的对象。到处都是。
Even Cookie Monster. Not Cookie Monster. What? We made that up. There was no Cookie Monster sings Chocolate Rain. They wrote that and after the episode aired, people made them. Oh, I didn't know that. Isn't that crazy?
甚至饼干怪兽。不是饼干怪兽。什么？那是我们编的。根本没有《饼干怪兽唱巧克力雨》。他们写了那个，在这一集播出后，人们才制作了它。哦，我不知道。那不疯狂吗？
That is crazy. You know, I did go to every version. you could imagine of this song. I looked it up. And I did notice the one where Cookie Monster is singing it. The first comment said, who else is here because of Michael Scott? Yeah, exactly. Well, Michael has opened the door to confession time and people are just letting it fly. Yeah. The big confession comes from Meredith, who says that she has been having a six-year affair with the hammer mill rep in exchange for discounts on our supplies and also outbacked Steakhouse gift certificates.
那太疯狂了。你知道，我确实看了这首歌你能想象到的每一个版本。我查了一下。我确实注意到了饼干怪兽唱的那一个。第一条评论说：“还有谁是因为迈克尔·斯科特才来这儿的？”是的，正是如此。好吧，迈克尔打开了忏悔时间的大门，人们只是畅所欲言。是的。最大的忏悔来自梅雷迪思，她说她和锤磨机代表有六年的婚外情，以换取我们的供应折扣，还有Outback牛排馆的礼品卡。
Bruce Myers. Bruce Myers and Meredith, six years. Now, here's something. Wasn't there in that previous episode, we finally landed the hammer mill rep when they went to that big conference and it was only a few? Remember? I think there's a little continuity catch here. Continuity error.
布鲁斯·迈尔斯。布鲁斯·迈尔斯和梅雷迪思，六年。现在，有一件事。在上一集里，当他们去那个大型会议时，我们不是终于拿下了锤磨机代表吗？记得吗？我想这里有一个连续性漏洞。连续性错误。
Yeah. So she's been sleeping with him for six years, but we only just landed him like two years ago. I don't know, Meredith. Show Bible. Show Bible. Sort it out, guys. Yeah. Holly is troubled.
是的。所以她和他睡了六年，但我们两年前才拿下他。我不知道，梅雷迪思。剧本圣经。剧本圣经。伙计们，理理清楚。是的。霍莉很困扰。
Oh, yeah. Holly is like, this is a serious ethics violation. I have to report this. Jenna, there was one other confession that rattled someone else. What? Ryan made a confession. And Kevin is like, what? This is the beginning of the runner.
哦，是的。霍莉觉得这是严重的道德违规。我必须报告这件事。珍娜，还有另一个忏悔让别人感到不安。什么？瑞安做了一个忏悔。凯文说：“什么？”这是这个梗的开始。
Sam, can you play it? Last year, you guys were riding me really hard for the website, and I just peeled out my Z3 and I knocked the mirror off somebody's car. I never said a thing. Wait, what? Kevin's like, what? And then immediately after this conference room scene, Kevin approaches Ryan in the kitchen and confronts him.
萨姆，你能播放一下吗？“去年，你们因为网站的事对我逼得很紧，我开着我的Z3，撞坏了别人的车镜。我什么都没说。”等等，什么？凯文说：“什么？”然后在这个会议室场景之后，凯文立刻在厨房里接近瑞安并与他对质。
You knocked the mirror off of my car. Yeah. Isn't that messed up? Yeah. That guy did a lot of things I'm not proud of. Wait. When you say that guy, do you mean you? I mean the guy I used to be.
“你撞坏了我的车镜。”“是的。那不是很糟糕吗？”“是的。那个家伙做了很多我不引以为傲的事。”“等等。当你提到那个家伙时，你是说你吗？”“我是指我曾经的那个家伙。”
I'm Ryan 2.0. And if it makes you feel any better, that guy did a lot of messed up stuff to me too. No, you mean that you did a lot of messed up stuff to you. Look, I feel you. Too. Okay? That guy took no responsibility for his actions.
“我是瑞安2.0。如果这能让你感觉好点，那个家伙也对我做了很多糟糕的事。”“不，你是说你对自己做了很多糟糕的事。”“听着，我理解你。也一样，好吗？那个家伙对他的行为不负责任。”
But are you? you're going to pay for my mirror. If I have to answer for everything that guy did, I'm never going to move on. It was like $200. We're never going to get what we need from that guy. You know my love of Ryan in this rewatch, and I am so sad that did not make it in the episode, but I am so glad it exists. I know.
“但你呢？你要赔我的镜子。”“如果我必须为那个家伙做的一切负责，我永远无法前进。”那大约是200美元。我们永远无法从那个家伙那里得到我们需要的东西。你知道我在重看时对瑞安的喜爱，我很遗憾它没能进入这一集，但我很高兴它存在。我知道。
I showed it to Sam, and Sam was like, I know these people. I know these people. Yeah, that's a good example of Los Angeles. But yeah, so Kevin gets Ryan back by putting his sunglasses, his really nice sunglasses in the toaster oven. Amazing. Melts them. But that was Kevin 1.0. Yeah, he can't be responsible for what that guy did.
我给萨姆看了，萨姆说：“我认识这些人。我认识这些人。”是的，那是洛杉矶的一个很好的例子。但是的，所以凯文通过把他的太阳镜，他非常好的太阳镜放进烤面包机里报复了瑞安。太棒了。融化了它们。但那是凯文1.0。是的，他不能为那个家伙做的事负责。
That's right. So that was the Ryan Kevin Runner that got deleted because we just ran out of time, but I thought it was so great. It's so good. So now we have the scene where Michael and Holly are going to meet privately with Meredith to discuss her. Liaison. Yes. You know, Michael is trying very hard to help Meredith say the things she needs to say to get out of trouble. Yeah. Meredith is not getting it. She's not getting it at all. And Kate is so funny in this scene. So funny. Well, we do have a classic gym prank. We get a gym prank. Yeah. It's been a bit. And I thought it was so funny. And I can tell that John and Rain were having such a good time. Just because we know them. Yeah. You gave John that prop. That stopwatch? He's loving that stopwatch.
没错。所以这就是那个被删掉的瑞安和凯文的梗，因为我们时间不够了，但我认为它太棒了。太好了。所以现在我们有了迈克尔和霍莉私下会见梅雷迪思讨论她的联络。是的。你知道，迈克尔非常努力地帮助梅雷迪思说出她需要说的话以摆脱麻烦。是的。梅雷迪思没明白。她根本没明白。凯特在这一幕里太搞笑了。太搞笑了。好吧，我们确实有一个经典的吉姆恶作剧。我们有一个吉姆恶作剧。是的。有一阵子了。我觉得这太搞笑了。我看得出约翰和雷恩玩得很开心。只是因为我们认识他们。是的。你给了约翰那个道具。那个秒表？他很喜欢那个秒表。
He's loving it. Yeah, Dwight had said in the conference room that he doesn't do anything personal at work. He wastes no time. Waste no time. So Jim's going to show him. He's going to like time every single thing he does. Well, right about now is when we would have gone to see Pam at art school. Mm-hmm.
他很喜欢它。是的，德怀特在会议室里说过他在工作中不做任何私事。他不浪费时间。不浪费时间。所以吉姆要给他展示一下。他要给他的每一件事计时。嗯，就在这个时候，我们本该去看看帕姆在艺术学校的情况。嗯。
And I'm going to tell you about it. Okay. So Pam and her classmates, they get to class, and there's a note on the door. No class today. It's canceled. canceled. So her friends are like, let's go get drinks. And Pam's like, I can't.
我要告诉你们。好吧。帕姆和她的同学们到了教室，门上有一张纸条。今天没课。取消了。取消了。所以她的朋友们说，去喝一杯吧。帕姆说，我不行。
And her friend Alex, who was played by Rich Summer, says, what do you have to do? You're supposed to be in class right now. We know you don't have plans. So they get her to go to this teaky bar for a little day drinking. And I totally remember shooting this, Angela. We're all drinking out of this big, giant volcano bowl. There's a flame. It's on fire.
她的朋友亚历克斯，由里奇·萨默饰演，说：“你必须做什么？你现在应该在教室里。我们知道你没计划。”所以他们带她去这个提基酒吧喝点日间酒。我完全记得拍摄这一幕，安吉拉。我们都在喝这个巨大的火山碗。有火焰。着火了。
Yeah. We had to have a safety meeting about it. And in the scene, two of the other art students, they're trying to decode this text message. They're wondering what to text back. Well, it's like a guy, right? So she's like wanting to text a guy back, but not seem like too into him. You know how you have to write the perfect text back to someone you're into, but you don't want to seem too desperate. Well, Pam is spiraling.
是的。我们不得不为此开一个安全会议。在这一幕中，另外两个艺术生试图解读这条短信。他们想知道回什么。嗯，是个男的，对吧？所以她想回短信给一个男的，但不想显得太迷他。你知道你怎么必须给一个你迷的人写完美的回复，但你不想显得太绝望。好吧，帕姆正在失控。
Remember I said in the other episode that we purposely cast people who would seem younger and hipper than Pam? So she would be this fish out of water in art school. Yeah. Well, she's kind of spiraling about that. And she has this great, crazy monologue that she blurts out. Sam, will you play the Pam Tiki bar scene for me? He put a wink at the end. Does that mean something?
记得我在另一集里说过，我们特意选了看起来比帕姆更年轻、更时髦的人吗？这样她在艺术学校就会像一条离水的鱼。是的。好吧，她有点失控了。她有一段很棒、很疯狂的独白。萨姆，你能为我播放帕姆提基酒吧的场景吗？“他在最后加了一个眨眼。那意味着什么？”
It means he's a dork. So how do I write back, you know, showing him that I'm also a dork? Oh, he knows. Don't ask me. I don't even know what I'm doing here. I'm like way older than you guys. I mean, like, I have a fiancé and I had like a tenure plan and like is graphic design, even art. At this point, I thought that I would be married and running my own art company. But I would just put like big LOL, little LOL winky face. Oh, okay.
“这意味着他是个书呆子。所以我该怎么回，你知道，向他展示我也是个书呆子？”“哦，他知道。别问我。我甚至不知道我在这儿干什么。我比你们大多了。我的意思是，我有未婚夫，我有十年计划，平面设计甚至是艺术吗？在这一点上，我以为我会结婚并经营自己的艺术公司。但我只会写大大的LOL，小小的LOL眨眼表情。哦，好吧。”
Okay, I thought that was so interesting. We just got a window into what Pam thought her life would be. She says at this point she thought she would be married and running her own art company. What does she mean by art company? I don't know. It sounds like something like a fifth grader. Yeah, like someday I'm going to own an art company. Does that mean she sells art supplies? Yeah.
好吧，我觉得这太有趣了。我们刚刚看到了帕姆认为她的生活会是什么样子的窗口。她说在这一点上她以为她会结婚并经营自己的艺术公司。她说的“艺术公司”是什么意思？我不知道。听起来像五年级学生说的话。是的，就像“有一天我要拥有一家艺术公司”。这是否意味着她卖艺术用品？是的。
What does she mean by that? I don't know. I thought it was so, it was such a window into Pam. I thought. I did too. And, you know, it goes on to show that she drank the whole volcano herself, basically. Yeah. There are more scenes at this bar.
她是什么意思？我不知道。我觉得这太……这是帕姆的一个窗口。我觉得。我也这么认为。而且，你知道，这继续表明她基本上自己喝了整座火山。是的。这个酒吧还有更多场景。
She gets really tipsy. But then she has this really peppy talking head where she says, if she were in Scranton right now, she'd be an alcoholic. But she's not. She's in New York. So she's a moody artist. She loves New York. Well, I was really bummed that these scenes got cut because one of the art students, the guy who you hear trying to help the girl with her text message, was played by one of my very good friends.
她变得很醉。但后来她有一个非常活泼的独白，她说如果她现在在斯克兰顿，她会是个酒鬼。但她不是。她在纽约。所以她是个忧郁的艺术家。她爱纽约。嗯，我很遗憾这些场景被剪掉了，因为其中一个艺术生，那个你听到试图帮助女孩回短信的家伙，是由我的一个好朋友饰演的。
in real life, John Cabrera. You might know him because he was a longtime cast member on Gilmore Girls. He played Brian Fuller. He was the bass player in Lane's band. So we filmed all of these scenes at Pam's Art School. They never made it into an episode. He doesn't even have a credit on IMDB for being on the office. Because all his scenes got cut, but we had the best time.
在现实生活中，约翰·卡布雷拉。你们可能认识他，因为他是《吉尔莫女孩》的长期演员。他饰演布莱恩·富勒。他是莱恩乐队的贝斯手。所以我们在帕姆的艺术学校拍摄了所有这些场景。它们从未进入任何一集。他在IMDB上甚至没有客串《办公室》的记录。因为他所有的场景都被剪掉了，但我们玩得很开心。
Jenna, have you ever had a volcano? No. Have you? Once. What? Once. I thought we made that up. That's a real thing. Is it on fire? Yes. Sam is nodding. Like, how many have you had, Sam? So that was the most aggressive I've ever.
珍娜，你喝过火山吗？没有。你喝过吗？一次。什么？一次。我以为是我们编的。那是真实存在的东西。它着火了吗？是的。萨姆在点头。就像，“你喝过多少次，萨姆？”所以那是我有史以来最激进的……
You are like... Yeah, it's a staple of the Tiki Bar community. Yeah. I've had one. That's all you'll ever need to have. I had one at a bar in Manhattan Beach for a friend's birthday. We got the volcano because my friend's birthday, you know, we were like 25 years old. It's a huge, huge, huge bowl. Okay. It comes on fire. Okay. All these different straws in it. It's usually a mixture of like pineapple or grapefruit or lime juice, maple syrup, several different types of rums. Okay. I felt real gross the next day.
你就像……是的，这是提基酒吧社区的主食。是的。我喝过一次。那是你唯一需要喝的。我在曼哈顿海滩的一家酒吧为朋友的生日喝过。我们点了火山，因为我朋友的生日，你知道，我们当时25岁。这是一个巨大巨大巨大的碗。好吧。它着火了。好吧。里面有各种各样的吸管。它通常是菠萝、葡萄柚或青柠汁、枫糖浆、几种不同类型的朗姆酒的混合物。好吧。第二天我感觉真的很恶心。
And what's so funny is I had Pam's experience. Like, you're just all drinking it. You can't tell who's had more or what because there's all these straws flopping out of it. And the photos from this evening are real special. We all decided to see if we could do the splits. Oh. Mm-hmm. It was one of those nights. I didn't do the splits. No, you do it. I do it. So, volcano guys, tread lightly. Am I too old to have this experience? I think so. Damn it. You won't feel good the next day. I missed my chance. I started drinking late in life. I know. I really did. I think it's okay that you navigated your life without having the volcano experience. I don't know. I'm having some fomo. Well, now Michael is going to invite Holly to lunch.
最有趣的是我有了帕姆的经历。就像，你们都在喝它。你分不清谁喝得更多或是什么，因为里面插满了吸管。那天晚上的照片真的很特别。我们都决定看看能不能劈叉。哦。嗯。那是那种夜晚之一。我没劈叉。不，你劈了。我劈了。所以，火山，伙计们，小心行事。我年纪太大不能有这种经历了吗？我想是的。该死。第二天你会感觉不好。我错过了机会。我晚年才开始喝酒。我知道。我真的错过了。我觉得你没喝过火山也过得很好。我不知道。我有种错失恐惧症。好吧，现在迈克尔要邀请霍莉去吃午餐。
Because it's okay if like two attractive people go to lunch, you know, they work together, they're attractive. Yes. They can eat lunch. It's not an official date. And there was a deleted Michael talking head that if it was an official date, Holly would know because it would go like this. No, this is not an official date. When it is an official date, she will be aware of it. There will be a rose.
因为如果两个有魅力的人去吃午餐是可以的，你知道，他们一起工作，他们很有魅力。是的。他们可以吃午餐。这不是正式约会。有一个被删掉的迈克尔独白，如果这是正式约会，霍莉会知道，因为会是这样的：“不，这不是正式约会。当它是正式约会时，她会意识到的。会有一朵玫瑰。”
there will be music and dancing a bottle of red, bottle of white, bottle of water, I've drink more water, some whispered conversation, some giggling, little wine, we head back to her place. I will skip ahead to protect our dignity, but
“会有音乐和舞蹈，一瓶红酒，一瓶白酒，一瓶水，我喝了更多的水，一些耳语，一些咯咯笑，一点葡萄酒，我们回到她的住处。我会跳过以保护我们的尊严，但是……”
we make hard, Love. And then we fall asleep on her line high to the sound of the full moon. And then chocolate chip pancakes. Okay, I haven't had a volcano, but I've had that date. You've had that date. I've had that date. That's a good date.
“我们做爱。然后我们在满月的月光下在她的线上睡着。然后是巧克力曲奇煎饼。”好吧，我没喝过火山，但我有过那种约会。你有过那种约会。我有过那种约会。那是个好约会。
I just want a shirt that says hardcore love. You got to fall asleep to the sound of the moon. You do. You do. Oh, well, he suggests that they go to Cooper's restaurant, and I've got some good information to share about that. So why don't we take a break and we'll come back. Great. All right.
我只是想要一件写着“硬核爱”的衬衫。你得在月亮的声音中睡着。你得这样。你得这样。哦，好吧，他建议他们去库珀餐厅，我有一些关于那个的好信息要分享。所以我们休息一下，回来再说。太棒了。好吧。
We are back. Michael and Holly have gone to lunch. We got fan questions from Kelly W. Sammy B. and Carolyn P. What is the restaurant that Holly and Michael went to? Angela, you saw the outside shot of this restaurant. Yeah, I've been there in real life. It is a real restaurant in Scranton called Cooperin. Cooper's Seafood House.
我们回来了。迈克尔和霍莉去吃午餐了。我们收到了凯利·W、萨米·B和卡罗琳·P的粉丝提问。霍莉和迈克尔去的餐厅是什么？安吉拉，你看到了这家餐厅的外景。是的，我在现实生活中去过那里。它是斯克兰顿一家真正的餐厅，叫库珀。库珀海鲜屋。
Mm-hmm. And we did not go to Cooper. So we used a shot of the outside. The interior, I got all the scoop from Jamesapedia. Jamesapedia is back. And Amy Ryan said they did an amazing job. Amazing, right? I looked at pictures online of the real Cooper's, and I compared them to screenshots because
嗯。我们没去库珀。所以我们用了外景镜头。内部，我从Jamesapedia得到了所有内幕。Jamesapedia回来了。艾米·瑞恩说他们做得太棒了。太棒了，对吧？我在网上看了真正的库珀的照片，我把它们和截图做了对比，因为……
that's what I do now, I guess. Yeah. It is that. Yeah. And we really congratulations to a. our set designers, they did a great job redressing this. What did James Epidia have? James Epidia said that we shot the interior at Clancy's Crabbroiler in Glendale, California, that we started shooting at 8 a.m. And there was a note on the call sheet. That said, the restaurant will be open for business at 11 a.m.
这就是我现在做的事，我想。是的。就是那个。是的。我们真的祝贺我们的布景设计师，他们出色地重新布置了这里。Jamesapedia有什么？Jamesapedia说我们在加州格伦代尔的Clancy's Crabbroiler拍摄了内部，我们早上8点开始拍摄。通告单上有一条说明。上面写着，餐厅将在上午11点营业。
So they had three hours to film all of those restaurant scenes. And I asked him, I said, now when it says they're to open back up at 11 a.m. Does that mean we have to be done filming and get all our stuff out? Because we changed the look of the restaurant. And he said what we would normally do is we would get in there really, really early and dress it, do our scenes and get out as much as we can by 11 o'clock. But they would go back the next day to like do a full cleanup. So the patrons that day ate in a kind of hybrid restaurant of Clancy's crab broiler slash Cooper Seafood. Say that 10 times fast. I could barely say it one. Crab broiler. Clancy's crab broiler. Well, here's a little something about Coopers.
所以他们只有三个小时来拍摄所有那些餐厅场景。我问他，我说，当上面写着他们上午11点重新开门时，那意味着我们必须拍完并把所有东西都搬走吗？因为我们改变了餐厅的样子。他说我们通常的做法是会非常非常早地进去布置，拍完我们的戏份，然后在11点前尽可能地撤离。但他们第二天会回去进行彻底的清理。所以那天顾客们是在一家混合了Clancy's蟹肉烧烤店和Cooper海鲜店的餐厅里用餐。试着快速说十遍。我连一遍都快说不出来了。蟹肉烧烤店。Clancy's蟹肉烧烤店。好吧，关于Cooper餐厅有一点小趣事。
All right. Brian Baumgartner and I went there in 2007 in Scranton. If you go to Cooper's Seafood House website online, there are a bunch of photos in their gallery section of Brian and I. I saw them. One in particular, I am barefoot and standing on top of a table. Oh, I missed that one. It's a good one. I'll put it in our stories.
好的。布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳和我2007年在斯克兰顿去过那里。如果你上网查看Cooper海鲜屋的网站，他们的画廊部分有很多我和布莱恩的照片。我看到了。其中一张特别的照片里，我赤着脚站在桌子上。哦，我错过了那张。那张很棒。我会把它放到我们的快拍里。
Clearly, Brian and I were there to have a good time. And we did. We had a blast. Well, this scene originally started with Michael ordering for he and Holly. Yes, he was going to be fancy man on a date. He said this restaurant was business romantic. Here's what he ordered. We'll have the chowders to start, then the lobster feast for two.
显然，我和布莱恩去那里是为了玩得开心。我们确实玩得很开心。我们玩疯了。嗯，这个场景最初是以迈克尔为他和霍莉点餐开始的。是的，他打算在约会时当个讲究的绅士。他说这家餐厅是“商务浪漫”风格的。这是他点的菜。我们要先来点杂烩汤，然后是双人龙虾盛宴。
and do you have a house red? And then he wants you to know, house makes a great red. Yes, I feel like, where did he come up with that? He heard that somewhere. Someone was like, the house wine is very good. The house makes a great red. And now he's like, he thinks the house is the winery.
还有你们有店里的红酒吗？然后他想让你知道，店里的红酒很棒。是的，我觉得，他是从哪儿想出这个的？他肯定在哪儿听过。有人说，店里的酒很好喝。店里的红酒很棒。现在他觉得“店里”就是一家酿酒厂。
Yes. Well, Holly says she just wants a chef salad, no dressing. With an iced tea. Yeah, she's not going to have any house red. And then the waitress says to Michael, do you still want the two lobsters? And Michael says, yes, yes, I do. Because now he's a little embarrassed.
是的。嗯，霍莉说她只想吃一份厨师沙拉，不要酱汁。配一杯冰茶。是的，她不打算喝任何店里的红酒。然后服务员问迈克尔，你还要那两份龙虾吗？迈克尔说，是的，是的，我要。因为现在他有点尴尬了。
So later in the scene, when you see Michael and he's got two lobsters and a big bowl of soup and a red wine, this is why. Yes, it's at 13 minutes, 44 seconds. You'll see how he ordered double. Incidentally, on the Cooper's menu, there is a recurring Tuesday special called Twin Tales and a cup of soup. And it is two lobster tails and a bread bowl of soup. And I am dying to know if this Tuesday special predated this episode of the office or if they created this as a special after Michael ordered two lobster tails and a bowl of soup. I don't know how to find out. Well, we'll have to go.
所以后来在场景中，当你看到迈克尔面前有两只龙虾、一大碗汤和一杯红酒时，原因就在这儿。是的，在13分44秒的时候。你会看到他是怎么点双份的。顺便说一句，在Cooper的菜单上，有一个每周二的常驻特价菜，叫“双尾龙虾配一碗汤”。它就是两只龙虾尾和一个面包碗装的汤。我非常想知道这个周二特价菜是在《办公室》这一集之前就有了，还是在迈克尔点了两只龙虾尾和一碗汤之后他们才把它作为特价菜推出的。我不知道怎么查证。好吧，我们得去一趟。
Anyone? Cooper's, anyone. Yeah. Well, here's the thing. We are going to Scranton. We are. I can't wait. Should we order two lobster tails and a bowl of soup and House Red?
有人吗？Cooper餐厅，有人吗？是的。嗯，事情是这样的。我们要去斯克兰顿。我们要去了。我等不及了。我们要不要点两只龙虾尾、一碗汤和店里的红酒？
Yes. We're going to do something. So much eating in Scranton. I know. Like the bulk of our trip there is just eating our way through Scranton. I know. Well, this lunch, it just is not going well. They cannot get on the same page about what to do with Meredith. They can't. Michael was trying to just connect with Holly, get to know her. He asked her, you know, about where she grew up, Des Moines. We find out she's from Des Moines, Iowa. Mm-hmm. Right. Holly is being business. This is a business lunch. And she feels gross about Meredith. They have this. this couplet of dialogue that really sums it up. Holly says, I'm saying that Meredith's behavior is unethical and a little icky, and I don't think I want to work in an environment where that sort of
是的。我们要去干点什么。在斯克兰顿吃得太多了。我知道。我们去那里的主要行程就是一路吃遍斯克兰顿。我知道。嗯，这顿午餐进行得不太顺利。关于如何处理梅雷迪思的问题，他们无法达成一致。他们做不到。迈克尔只是想和霍莉建立联系，了解她。他问她，你知道，关于她在哪儿长大，得梅因。我们发现她是来自爱荷华州得梅因的。嗯哼。对。霍莉在谈公事。这是一顿商务午餐。她觉得梅雷迪思的事很恶心。他们有这段对话，真的总结了这一点。霍莉说，我说的是梅雷迪思的行为是不道德的，而且有点恶心，我不认为我想在一个容忍那种行为的环境中工作。
conduct is tolerated. Michael says, well, you have to tolerate a lot when you're a part of a family. And Holly delivers such a low blow, if you know Michael. She says, it's not a family. It's a workplace. Oh my gosh, the look on his face. Like, how do they come back from this? Meanwhile, back at the office, Jim is really trying to trap Dwight into wasting time. He's trying to get him to have personal conversations. He tries to explain an episode of Battlestar Galactica to Andy, purposely getting everything wrong and inserting all kinds of other characters. All kinds of other characters. He says it's like the crazy monsters and stuff.
迈克尔说，嗯，当你是一个家庭的一员时，你必须容忍很多事情。然后霍莉给了他沉重的一击，如果你了解迈克尔的话。她说，这不是家庭。这是工作场所。天哪，他脸上的表情。他们怎么从这儿挽回局面？与此同时，在办公室里，吉姆真的在试图诱导德怀特浪费时间。他试图让他进行私人谈话。他试图向安迪解释一集《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》，故意把所有内容都说错，并插入各种其他角色。各种各样的其他角色。他说就像疯狂的怪物之类的。
There's Klingons and wookies. He says there's a guy named Dumbledore. They're trying to get a ring back to Mordor. This is triggering every button. in Dwight. I loved Rain in the scene where he just was. And I also just loved the way John would hold up the stopwatch. Oh yeah. They were doing this beautiful, like, comedic dance. It was so good. It was so good. You know, we had a fan point out. Lindsay H. said, I am so impressed with the camera focus when Jim is talking to Andy about Battlestar Galactica slash Star Wars slash Harry Potter slash Lord of the Rings slash Star Wars. Anyway, she says the camera focuses on Jim, then Dwight, and back and forth so quickly and flawlessly. She just wanted to give kudos to our camera operators. Yeah. Yeah, because I mean, John and Rain are doing this dance,
有克林贡人和伍基人。他说有个叫邓布利多的人。他们正试图把一枚戒指送回魔多。这触动了德怀特的所有神经。我喜欢雷恩在这个场景里的表现，他当时的样子。我也很喜欢约翰举起秒表的方式。哦，是的。他们正在进行一场美丽的、喜剧般的舞蹈。太棒了。太棒了。你知道，有粉丝指出。琳赛·H说，我对吉姆和安迪谈论《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》斜杠《星球大战》斜杠《哈利波特》斜杠《指环王》斜杠《星球大战》时的镜头焦点印象深刻。总之，她说镜头在吉姆和德怀特之间切换得如此迅速且完美无瑕。她只是想向我们的摄像师致敬。是的。是的，因为我的意思是，约翰和雷恩在跳这支舞，
but they're in it with the camera operator, and that was flawless. I agree, Lindsay. Me too. We also had a fan catch from Justin S. Jenna, I know you and Phyllis are both from St. Louis, and I'm a big Cardinals fan myself, and I couldn't help but notice that there is a freebird on Phyllis's desk over Dwight's shoulder. And I was just wondering, how did the free bird get there? Guys, I texted Phyllis about it. Yeah? We don't know.
但他们和摄像师配合得很好，那真是完美无瑕。我同意，琳赛。我也是。我们还有一位粉丝贾斯汀·S的发现。珍娜，我知道你和菲利斯都来自圣路易斯，我自己也是红雀队的忠实粉丝，我忍不住注意到菲利斯的桌子上，在德怀特的肩膀后面有一个“自由鸟”。我只是想知道，那只自由鸟是怎么到那儿的？伙计们，我给菲利斯发了短信问这件事。是吗？我们不知道。
She said, oh, maybe that was when David Fries and Matt Holliday came to visit. And I was like, no, they haven't come to visit yet. I'll tell you guys that story later. That was amazing. You guys were so excited. And I know they hadn't visited yet because Ellie was with us when they visited. So Phyllis and I went back and forth and she's like, I didn't bring it in. She said, I don't know who put it there.
她说，哦，也许那是大卫·弗里斯和马特·霍利来访的时候。我说，不，他们还没来访过。我以后再告诉你们那个故事。那太棒了。你们当时太兴奋了。我知道他们还没来访过，因为埃莉和我们在一起的时候他们才来访。所以菲利斯和我来回确认，她说，我没把它带进来。她说，我不知道是谁把它放在那儿的。
I didn't put it there. Phyllis didn't put it there. We don't know who put it there. Well, Justin, I'm sorry. I'm going to try to get to the bottom of it, you know, answer pending. Yeah. Jim has a talking head that Dwight hasn't stopped working for a second. He even sneezed with his eyes open, which Jim was like, I didn't know that was possible.
我没把它放在那儿。菲利斯没把它放在那儿。我们不知道是谁把它放在那儿的。好吧，贾斯汀，我很抱歉。我会试着查个水落石出，你知道，等待答案中。是的。吉姆有一个采访镜头，说德怀特一秒钟都没停下工作。他甚至睁着眼睛打喷嚏，吉姆当时觉得，我不知道这居然可能。
You guys, he peed in a soda bottle. He peed under his desk. I mean, he is not going to waste any time. I had to know if you can sneeze with your eyes open. You can't. You can. What? Yeah. Mythbusters did a whole story on it. Mythbusters. And I watched it late last night when I suddenly had to know. We both went on two random tangents. Just wait for mine. Is yours about the average amount of time someone has sex? Because I went on that tangent too. Yes! Yes! All of a sudden, Dwight is like not wasting time, not wasting time. And then he comes back and Jim is like 19 minutes and 48 seconds. What were you up to? And Dwight is like none of your business, basically. And then it cuts to Angela Martin buttoning her blouse. Did you read the research on Business Insider? I read several articles at like midnight last night. Me too.
伙计们，他在汽水瓶里撒尿了。他在桌子底下撒尿。我的意思是，他一点时间都不浪费。我必须知道人能不能睁着眼睛打喷嚏。不能。能。什么？是的。《流言终结者》做过一整期节目。流言终结者。我昨晚很晚的时候看了，因为我突然必须知道。我们俩都跑题了。你的是关于人们性生活的平均时长吗？因为我也跑题到那儿了。是的！是的！突然之间，德怀特好像没在浪费时间，没在浪费时间。然后他回来，吉姆说19分48秒。你刚才在干什么？德怀特基本上说不关你的事。然后镜头切到安吉拉·马丁在扣衬衫扣子。你读过《商业内幕》上的那项研究吗？我昨晚午夜左右读了好几篇文章。我也是。
Our search history. Oh my God. Delete our search history. First of all, the one research I read about was fascinating because they gave 500 couples. Yep. Stopwatches. It is as awkward as it sounds. They had to hit start and stop.
我们的搜索记录。天哪。删除我们的搜索记录。首先，我读到的那项研究非常引人入胜，因为他们给了500对夫妇。是的。秒表。这听起来有多尴尬就有多尴尬。他们必须按下开始和停止键。
I don't know how we talk about this. But maybe parents, if you're listening with your kids. Earmuffs for 30 seconds. Earmuffs. Yeah. They had to record their sex time. over a four-week period. Yeah.
我不知道我们该怎么谈论这个。但也许家长们，如果你们和孩子一起听的话。捂住耳朵30秒。捂住耳朵。是的。他们必须记录他们的性生活时长。在四周的时间里。是的。
And they had to press start on the stopwatch at the moment of penetration. Oh, God. And they had to press stop at ejaculation. We read the same article. Oh, my God. You know what? I found amazing is the range was from 33 seconds to 44 minutes. Yeah.
他们必须在插入的那一刻按下秒表上的开始键。哦，天哪。他们必须在射精时按下停止键。我们读的是同一篇文章。哦，天哪。你知道我觉得最神奇的是，范围从33秒到44分钟不等。是的。
That's a huge, huge variation. It is. And then what was really interesting to me was I read this whole article by a sex therapist who, after doing a bunch of research, broke down the ideal amount of penetration time in a sex act. I mean, this is insane. I told Lee all last night everything I'd read. He's like, how are you sharing this on office ladies? I was like, I don't know, but I found it so fascinating. I know. So what she found was that in surveying the person being penetrated, that their ideal amount of penetration time in sex was anywhere from five to 11 minutes. But all of sex, they all wanted more than just penetration. So she deemed that like the ideal amount of sex encompassing more than. just that moment would be around 19 minutes and that it should consist of 10 minutes of foreplay and nine minutes of actual intercourse that she felt this was the bullseye after all of her research.
那是一个巨大、巨大的差异。确实。然后对我来说真正有趣的是，我读了性治疗师写的整篇文章，她在做了大量研究后，分析了性行为中理想的插入时间。我的意思是，这太疯狂了。我昨晚把读到的一切都告诉了李。他说，你怎么能在《办公室女士》里分享这个？我说，我不知道，但我发现它太迷人了。我知道。所以她发现，在调查被插入的一方时，他们理想的性行为插入时间在5到11分钟之间。但对于整个性行为，他们都想要不仅仅是插入。所以她认为，包含更多内容的理想性行为时长应该在19分钟左右，应该包括10分钟的前戏和9分钟的实际性交，她觉得这是她所有研究后的靶心。
Okay. Well, something I discovered in my research is that of these 500 couples surveyed, the average time was 5.4 minutes. And this was true across continents. I mean, literally, it's a global thing. And this got me to thinking, 19 minutes and 48 seconds. Yeah. I did the math.
好的。嗯，我在研究中发现，在这500对受访夫妇中，平均时间是5.4分钟。这在各大洲都是如此。我的意思是，从字面上看，这是一个全球性的现象。这让我开始思考，19分48秒。是的。我算了算。
I think it took them six minutes to get down to the warehouse. Six minutes to walk down a set of stairs? Or take the elevator. It's not close. They have to go in the elevator, our stairs, and they have to go down the corridor through the warehouse to that back room, open it up. All right, so six minutes to get there. They need six minutes back.
我想他们花了六分钟才走到仓库。走下一段楼梯要六分钟？或者坐电梯。那儿不近。他们必须进电梯，或者走楼梯，然后他们必须穿过走廊，穿过仓库到那个后屋，打开它。好吧，所以到那儿要六分钟。他们回来也需要六分钟。
That leaves them six minutes in the middle. Oh. I think they had six minutes to shag. I mean, I think what we've discovered in all our research is you can have a really satisfying shag in six minutes. By the way, this article went on to the evolution of sex. Why is there thrusting? It was fascinating. I was fascinated.
中间就剩下六分钟了。哦。我想他们有六分钟的时间来做爱。我的意思是，我认为我们在所有研究中发现的是，你可以在六分钟内进行一次非常令人满意的性爱。顺便说一句，这篇文章还谈到了性行为的进化。为什么会有抽动？这太迷人了。我被迷住了。
Oh, the things we have learned. And shared with you all. So you're welcome. Well, let's get back to this Michael Hawley story. Okay? This whole lunch has really strained things between Michael and Holly. When he gets back, he has a talking head where he says he won't even ride the elevator with her. And then he throws her leftovers in the trash.
哦，我们学到的东西。并与你们所有人分享。所以不客气。好吧，让我们回到迈克尔和霍莉的故事。好吗？整个午餐让迈克尔和霍莉之间的关系变得非常紧张。当他回来时，他有一个采访镜头，说他甚至不会和她一起坐电梯。然后他把她的剩菜扔进了垃圾桶。
Yeah. And then up in the kitchen, he's pouring himself some coffee. She puts her cup out. Not only does he not pour coffee in her cup, he takes the whole pot and walks out of the kitchen. She called Dundra Mifflin a workplace. And it is his family. And you do not do that. You do not.
是的。然后在厨房里，他给自己倒咖啡。她把杯子递过去。他不仅没有往她的杯子里倒咖啡，还拿着整个咖啡壶走出了厨房。她把邓德·米夫林称为工作场所。而这是他的家庭。你不能那样做。你不能。
If Holly wants to use the copier now, she's going to have to wait for Michael to copy a plaque off the wall first. Yeah. Well, Holly has a talking head. Things are tense. People are suspicious of her. Her best friend in the office won't even speak to her. So now we have a little window into Holly. She really sees Michael as her best friend.
如果霍莉现在想用复印机，她得等迈克尔先复印完墙上的牌匾。是的。嗯，霍莉有一个采访镜头。气氛很紧张。人们对她很怀疑。她在办公室里最好的朋友甚至不跟她说话。所以现在我们对霍莉有了一点了解。她真的把迈克尔视为她最好的朋友。
Now, Angela, in the script, there was a scene. here where Michael calls Toby. Yes. For help with Holly. Yes, it's in the deleted scenes. Oh, guys, it's so good because Toby basically says at the end of all of this, oh, well, Michael, I think Holly's doing the right thing. And in fact, now that you've told me, I'm obligated to report this Meredith incident
现在，安吉拉，在剧本里，这里有一个场景，迈克尔给托比打了电话。是的。寻求关于霍莉的帮助。是的，在删除的场景里。哦，伙计们，太棒了，因为托比在这一切结束时基本上说，哦，好吧，迈克尔，我想霍莉做的是对的。事实上，既然你告诉了我，我有义务报告这个梅雷迪思事件
to HR as well. Yeah. But that's how desperate Michael is, is he's going to call Toby, who I guess is still in a hospital in Costa Rica? And he's still not nice to him. He calls Toby for help, but he's still not nice. This is not the last HR rep that's going to be involved. Kendall from corporate has called, and Holly's going to come in Michael's office, and they're going to discuss it with Kendall. Yeah. We had a fan question from Megan Q. Who voices Kendall from corporate HR? Kendall was played by John Hartman. Now, the role of Kendall was first mentioned in the episode
给人力资源部。是的。但这就是迈克尔有多绝望，他居然要给托比打电话，我猜他还在哥斯达黎加的医院里？而且他对他还是不友好。他打电话给托比求助，但他还是不友好。这不是最后一个会参与进来的人力资源代表。总部的肯德尔打来了电话，霍莉要进迈克尔的办公室，他们要和肯德尔讨论这件事。是的。我们有一个来自梅根·Q的粉丝提问。谁为总部人力资源部的肯德尔配音？肯德尔由约翰·哈特曼饰演。现在，肯德尔这个角色第一次在剧集中被提到
the job when David Wallace mentions his dislike for the HR rep Kendall during Jim's job interview in New York. Wow, that's a major callback. I know, but we also brought him up again in weight loss, I guess. And here's the thing. Kendall is going to come back two more times this season. He comes back in person in stress relief and company picnic. He's always played by John Hartman. You might recognize John, he had roles in Mad Men, Arrested Development, The Good Place, Blackish, Space Force, and Monk. Oh, there it is. Of course. There it is. Well, you think Kendall is going to get Holly's back, right, and agree with her. But instead, he just shuts her down, says he doesn't really see this
是在“工作”那一集，大卫·华莱士在吉姆于纽约面试时提到了他不喜欢人力资源代表肯德尔。哇，那是一个重大的呼应。我知道，但我猜我们在“减肥”那一集又提到了他。事情是这样的。肯德尔这一季还会再出现两次。他亲自出现在“压力缓解”和“公司野餐”中。他一直由约翰·哈特曼饰演。你可能认得约翰，他在《广告狂人》、《发展受阻》、《善地》、《黑人一家亲》、《太空部队》和《神探阿蒙》中都有角色。哦，原来如此。当然。原来如此。嗯，你以为肯德尔会支持霍莉，对吧，并同意她的观点。但相反，他只是让她闭嘴，说他并不真的认为这
as a huge infraction, and what she needed to do was to get everyone through that binder. That was her job. Yeah. We just needed you to get signatures. Are you able to get signatures or not? Because every other branch got signatures. And I think Michael feels badly for her in this moment. I feel badly for her. I do too. She's doing the right thing and corporate doesn't have her back. So Holly is just going to go out to the bullpen and say, hey, guys, I have to finish this ethics training. She has to finish reading from the binder so she can say she did it. No one is giving her any respect. Well, Michael's going to step up.
是一个巨大的违规行为，她需要做的是让每个人都看完那个活页夹。那是她的工作。是的。我们只需要你拿到签名。你能不能拿到签名？因为其他所有分部都拿到了签名。我觉得迈克尔在这一刻为她感到难过。我也为她感到难过。我也有同感。她做的是对的，而总部不支持她。所以霍莉只是走到办公区说，嘿，伙计们，我必须完成这个道德培训。她必须读完活页夹里的内容，这样她才能说她完成了。没有人尊重她。嗯，迈克尔要站出来了。
Yeah. Because he does feel bad for her. So he goes out there and he goes, if you don't get in there, no, no, he like loses it. It's so funny. Everyone goes in. She reads from the binder. And the look on Michael's face as she's like reading from the boring binder.
是的。因为他确实为她感到难过。所以他走出去说，如果你不进去，不，不，他好像崩溃了。太搞笑了。每个人都进去了。她读了活页夹里的内容。当她读着无聊的活页夹时，迈克尔脸上的表情。
He's in love again. Well, I don't think he ever fell out of love. They had their first spat. I guess they did. Yeah. Because Holly looks appreciative. They're both like, Oh, okay. We're back.
他又恋爱了。嗯，我不认为他曾经不爱过。他们只是有了第一次争吵。我想他们确实有了。是的。因为霍莉看起来很感激。他们俩都像，哦，好吧。我们回来了。
We're going to get through this. Yeah. At the very end of this episode, we have a tag. Everyone's in the break room. They're eating steak that was clearly provided by Meredith. We had a fan question from Kelly W. Okay, Kelly, what is it? During the last scene when everyone's eating steak in the break room, what is everyone
我们要度过这个难关。是的。在这一集的最后，我们有一个片尾彩蛋。每个人都在休息室。他们正在吃显然是梅雷迪思提供的牛排。我们有一个来自凯莉·W的粉丝提问。好的，凯莉，是什么？在最后每个人在休息室吃牛排的场景中，每个人
actually eating? Is it prop food or actually real expensive steak? And Savi A wants to know, Angela, what were you eating, Cindy? your character is a vegetarian. I was eating potatoes. That's what it looked like to me. I was eating potatoes. That's something we thought about.
实际上在吃什么？是道具食物还是真正昂贵的牛排？萨维·A想知道，安吉拉，你在吃什么，辛迪？你的角色是素食主义者。我在吃土豆。在我看来就是那样。我在吃土豆。那是我们考虑过的事情。
One of the things that Peter and Vartan shared is that our prop food was amazingly good food. Oh, yeah. That they didn't give us, like, kind of crappy food to eat in scenes. And Peter and Vartan would work with props, but I would have to think that Phil Shea and his team got us really good food from a restaurant. That was going to be my guess. Whenever I ate food in a scene, it was delicious. Yeah. So it was probably some really good steak. Yeah. What a day at work. Hey guys, come in and eat these steak and ribs for an hour.
彼得和瓦尔坦分享的一件事是，我们的道具食物是非常好的食物。哦，是的。他们没有给我们那种糟糕的食物在场景里吃。彼得和瓦尔坦会和道具组合作，但我认为菲尔·谢和他的团队从餐厅给我们弄来了非常好的食物。那本来会是我的猜测。每当我在场景里吃食物时，它都很美味。是的。所以那可能是一些非常好的牛排。是的。工作的一天。嘿伙计们，进来吃这些牛排和排骨一个小时。
Angela, you can have these potatoes. Sorry, Ange. Well, there you have it. That's business ethics. Yeah. Thank you so much to Amy Ryan. And thank you to James O'Carry for giving me the lowdown on Coopers. And thank you to B.J. Novak for pitching Peter and Vartan and Sergio and Allen to do the DVD commentary. That was just so wonderful. If you guys love the show, you'll love these commentaries. Well, I think on that note, you might go have a volcano. And I hope all of you guys have some hardcore love in your life for approximately 19 minutes. Or an average of six minutes. That would be fine. See you next week. Bye, guys. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
安吉拉，你可以吃这些土豆。抱歉，安吉。好吧，这就是全部内容。这就是商业道德。是的。非常感谢艾米·瑞安。也感谢詹姆斯·奥卡里给我提供了关于Cooper餐厅的内幕消息。还要感谢B.J.诺瓦克邀请彼得、瓦尔坦、塞尔吉奥和艾伦来做DVD评论。那真是太棒了。如果你们喜欢这部剧，你们会喜欢这些评论的。嗯，我想说到这儿，你们可能会去喝一杯火山鸡尾酒。我希望你们所有人生命中都有一些热烈的爱，持续大约19分钟。或者平均六分钟。那也很好。下周见。再见，伙计们。感谢收听《办公室女士》的“第二杯”。本集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。
Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. Our Second Drinks episodes are produced by Molly Nugent. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Brow. Lady, have you ever invested in something that seemed really amazing at first, but then did not live up to the hype? I once got this kind of fancy jacket that looked amazing in the store, but then I wore it out once,
我们的高级制片人是马特·比格尔。我们的“第二杯”剧集由莫莉·纽金特制作。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是Creed Brow的《Ruppertree》。女士，你有没有投资过什么起初看起来非常棒，但后来却名不副实的东西？我曾经买过一件那种看起来很时髦的夹克，在店里看起来棒极了，但我穿出去过一次，
and I realized it was not comfortable, and now it just lives in my closet collecting dust. LinkedIn has a word for that. Bullspend. Bullspend is when you optimize for numbers that look great. Impressions, reach, reactions. but then those numbers don't actually drive revenue. Invest in what actually looks good to your CFO. LinkedIn ads generate the highest ROAS, 121% of all major ad networks. You can reach the right buyers by targeting company, industry, job title, and more.
我意识到它一点也不舒服，现在它就待在我的衣柜里积灰。LinkedIn有一个词来形容这种情况。“公牛支出”（Bullspend）。“公牛支出”是指你为了那些看起来很棒的数据而优化。展示量、覆盖面、互动。但这些数据实际上并没有带来收入。投资于那些对你的首席财务官来说真正好看的东西。LinkedIn广告产生最高的广告支出回报率，占所有主要广告网络的121%。你可以通过定位公司、行业、职位等来接触到合适的买家。
So cut the bull spend. Advertise on LinkedIn, the network that works for you. Spend $250 on your first campaign on LinkedIn ads and get a $250 credit for the next one. just go to linkton.com slash office that's linkedin.com slash office terms and conditions apply There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以削减那些“公牛支出”。在LinkedIn上投放广告，这个网络为你工作。在LinkedIn广告上为你的第一个活动花费250美元，并为下一个活动获得250美元的抵用金。只需访问linkton.com/office，即linkedin.com/office，条款和条件适用。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。